Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 27, Artificial Intelligence Theory. Take it away, Jason. Hey, so we're back from vacation. Pretty excited about that. Yeah, we took a break.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、独立服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 27 期，人工智能理论。请开始，Jason。嘿，我们度假回来了。对此感到挺兴奋的。对，我们休息了一段时间。
Sorry, that was my fault. No, it wasn't your fault. Well, it wasn't really my fault. It was the end of the season. Oh, yes. And now it's the beginning of another. We're starting a new season. We're pretty excited, though, to be back.
抱歉，那是我的错。不，不是你的错。好吧，其实也不算我的错。那是赛季结束的时候。哦，对的。现在是另一个赛季的开始。我们要开始新的一季了。不过，能回来我们还是很兴奋的。
It works for TV shows, so why doesn't it work for us yeah i mean they have to go celebrate on their private island that they bought in the bahamas with all their millions as actors and just like we did yeah that's that's exactly what the show earned us our first million dollars and so we took a couple weeks off yeah right wait that's not what happened to you wait you made oh, I owe you your share. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I spent it all already.
这在电视剧里管用，那为什么对我们不管用呢？是啊，我的意思是他们不得不去他们在巴哈马群岛买的私人岛屿上庆祝，用他们作为演员赚来的几百万美元，就像我们做的那样。对，这正是节目为我们赚到的第一个一百万美元，所以我们休假了几个星期。对啊，等等，你不是这么过的，等等，你赚了……哦，我欠你那份。对不起。对不起。我已经全部花光了。
No, I'm Margaritas. We'll just have to do another 26 episodes. Yep. Yeah, pretty exciting to do our 27th episode. And yeah, I have the first news article. It's pretty interesting. I posted this on G+. So some of you who are
不，我用来买玛格丽塔酒了。我们只能再做 26 期节目了。是的。耶，录制我们的第 27 期节目挺让人兴奋的。是的，我有一篇头条新闻。挺有意思的。我把它发到了 G+ 上。所以有些
following the programming third-round community got sort of a sneak peek on this article. But yeah, I thought it was pretty funny. Basically, an indie game company made a game dev tycoon, which is sort of like one of these sim, you know, there's these like SimCity kind of games where you have some complex adaptive system, So just some sort of system that's running around. And your job is to sort of tease apart these variables that you don't really know. Like, for example, in SimCity, you know, there's, like, crime is created from residential zones. And you put police stations to reduce the crime. But that takes money and space.
关注 Programming Throwdown 社区的人对这篇文章有了一个大概的了解。不过，是的，我觉得挺搞笑的。基本上，一家独立游戏公司制作了一款《游戏开发大亨》（Game Dev Tycoon），这有点像模拟游戏，你知道的，有那种《模拟城市》之类的游戏，你拥有某种复杂的自适应系统，也就是某种正在运行的系统。你的工作就是剖析这些你并不真正了解的变量。比如，在模拟城市里，你知道，犯罪是由住宅区产生的。你放置警察局来减少犯罪。但这需要金钱和空间。
And so you have to make these tradeoffs, things like that. And you start to... I think you just sucked all the fun out of SimCity. You start to learn the dynamics. Half of the fun is learning the dynamics of the sim and all that. These guys made a game dev sim where you're like a few guys in a basement.
所以你必须做出这些权衡，诸如此类。然后你开始……我觉得你把《模拟城市》所有的乐趣都抽干了。你开始了解其中的动态。乐趣的一半就在于了解模拟游戏的动态以及所有这些。这些家伙做了一个游戏开发模拟游戏，里面你就像地下室里的几个家伙。
You make choices about what you want to spend your money on about making a game. Hacking on games and you can choose. Do I want to buy like the ps3 dev kit which costs a hundred thousand dollars but has a lot but neither of us have played this game so this is speculation oh you did oh you played oh never mind jason has played this game yeah um but uh you know or just make a pc game on the web so it's pretty fun um it's kind of a cute theme cute story so they did something pretty fun where they
你对把钱花在制作游戏上做出选择。捣鼓游戏，你可以选择。我是不是想买比如售价十万美元但有很多功能的 PS3 开发套件？不过我们俩都没玩过这个游戏，所以这只是猜测。哦，你玩过？哦，你玩过，哦，没关系，Jason 玩过这个游戏。嗯……不过，你知道的，或者只是在网上做个 PC 游戏，所以挺好玩的。嗯，这是一个挺可爱的题材，可爱的故事，所以他们做了一件挺有趣的事，就是
released a quote-unquote cracked version of their own game as soon as they released the game and put it on pirate bay um what they did was if you pirated the game using you know their cracked version um about halfway through the game people start pirating your in-game games that you're producing. You must go deeper. And you run out of money and you fail the game. And I thought it was pretty fun.
发布了他们自己游戏的所谓破解版，游戏一发售就放到了海盗湾上。嗯，他们做的是，如果你用他们的破解版盗版了这个游戏，大约玩到游戏中途的时候，人们开始盗版你正在制作的游戏。你必须深入下去。然后你钱花光了，游戏失败了。我觉得挺有趣的。
So the pirates keep stealing enough that you can never win. Yeah, exactly. So you start to just do worse and worse and worse. Yeah. So it's like effectively a not-demo demo. Yeah, yeah. It's basically,
所以海盗们一直偷，偷到你永远无法获胜。对，没错。所以你开始表现得越来越差。对。所以这实际上是一个“非演示版的演示版”。对，对。基本上，
it's the illusion that you're getting the full game, but you're really getting you know the first 30 days of game time or whatever but i mean i think that's fair like yeah i mean people this is what people always say right like oh i download this game so i can see if i like it or not if i like it i'll buy it yeah but if you play it halfway through before this happens or essentially you really liked it you should have probably bought it by then yeah i mean i was super pissed but i know i'm just kidding oh no the truth goes out right but uh it's a pretty funny article some people posted on their forums saying hey
它给人一种你得到了完整游戏的错觉，但实际上你得到的是前 30 天的游戏时间或者随便什么。不过我的意思是，我觉得这很公平，就像，人们总是这么说，对吧？就像，哦，我下载这个游戏是为了看看我喜不喜欢。如果我喜欢，我就会买。是的。但是如果你在发生这种情况之前玩了一半，或者本质上你真的很喜欢它，你到那时可能就已经买下了。是的，我的意思是，我超级生气，但我知道，我只是开玩笑。哦，不，真相大白了，对吧？不过……这是一篇挺搞笑的文章。有些人发帖到论坛上说，嘿，
hirers keep you know stealing my game can i research drm in that game and stuff like that so oh wait that'd be really funny actually i want to learn how to drm the game and stuff like that. Oh, wait, that would be really funny, actually. I want to learn how to DRM the game that I cracked. I want to learn to DRM in the game, which, oh, God, this is confusing. Totally inception moment there. Yeah, this has happened before. A couple people have done this, like, where I think one person, like, released a version of the game, but in the game you wear a pirate hat
黑客们一直在偷我的游戏，我能研究那个游戏里的 DRM 吗？诸如此类的话。哦，等等，那其实真的很好笑。我想学习如何给游戏加上 DRM 以及诸如此类的事情。哦，等等，那其实真的很搞笑。我想学习如何给我破解的游戏加上 DRM。我想学习在游戏中加入 DRM，哦，天哪，这太让人迷糊了。完全是《盗梦空间》的时刻。是的，这种事以前发生过。有几个人这样做过，比如，我想有一个人发布了一个游戏版本，但在游戏里如果你下载了这个版本，你会戴上一顶海盗帽。
if you download the version. Like, just, like, to be cutesy, like like remind you or whatever actually but but legally like i guess it's weird right because if you can't get in trouble for downloading a cracked version that the publisher put out uh so like i think yeah not that these people i think these people have no intention of suing the the people stealing but i don't think you ever like right you couldn't sue somebody for downloading a version you released. Yeah, I mean, and also there's an element of entrapment too, like if there's a game and it's
就像，只是为了可爱，为了提醒你或者什么的。不过，从法律上讲，我觉得这很奇怪，对吧？因为如果你下载了发行商发布的破解版，你不会惹上麻烦。所以，我想，是的，虽然这些人——我觉得这些人根本没打算起诉那些盗版的人，但我不认为你永远会……对吧？你不能起诉下载你发布的版本的人。是的，而且这里面也有诱捕的成分，比如如果有一款游戏，它又
new and it's hot, and you put it out on Pirate Bay immediately, maybe some people couldn't even buy it yet, I mean, I don't know exactly when they put it out and when they made the game available in different countries and whatnot, but you might get someone to pirate the game who wouldn't have if you hadn't done that, right? So, yeah, I don't think you can go after them. But actually, there
新又火，你立刻把它放到海盗湾上，也许有些人甚至还买不到它，我是说，我不知道他们具体是什么时候发布的，也不知道他们是什么时候让游戏在不同国家上市的，等等，但你可能会让一个本来不会盗版的人去盗版游戏，对吧？所以，是的，我不认为你能追究他们的责任。但实际上，有
was one game, I think it was Squaresoft. They made a game for Android. This is pretty cruel. Oh, no, no, it was Earthbound. Remember the game Earthbound for Nintendo? Vaguely. Vaguely. So, if you copied that game, like if you tried to dump the ROM, they had something in the game. I don't remember specifics, but you'd get to the boss after playing for 30 or 40 hours, and the game would crash, like purposely crash right there. That's pretty devastating.
一个游戏，我想是 Squaresoft。他们为 Android 做了一款游戏。这挺残酷的。哦，不，不，那是《地球冒险》（Earthbound）。还记得任天堂的《地球冒险》那个游戏吗？隐约记得。隐约记得。所以，如果你复制了那个游戏，比如你试图转储 ROM，他们在游戏里加了点东西。我不记得具体细节了，但你玩了 30 或 40 小时后到达Boss战时，游戏会崩溃，就像故意在那里崩溃一样。这挺让人崩溃的。
Well, on a similar thing, talking about Pirates, the much-hyped dude Daft Punk album, Random Access Memories. Pretty awesome. I don't't think as of this recording i don't think they have actually even fully released it yet but what they did was on itunes you can actually go on your computer and stream the whole album so there's a couple interesting caveats one is that like it streams all at once so i went and listened to it but like there's no track so you have to listen like you can pause it and come back and you can move around in the song i think but you can't actually like do like next track next track or shuffle or any of that right you just listen front to back the quality seemed okay i wasn't really like listening to it in an environment
嗯，类似的事情，说到海盗，备受炒作的蠢朋克（Daft Punk）专辑《超时空记忆》（Random Access Memories）。相当棒。我觉得在录制这期节目的时候，他们甚至还没有完全发行它，但他们做的是在 iTunes 上，你实际上可以去你的电脑上流媒体播放整张专辑。所以有几个有趣的注意事项。一个是它是一次性流式传输的，所以我去听了，但没有音轨，所以你必须听……你可以暂停然后回来，我想你可以在歌曲中快进，但你实际上不能做下一首、下一首或随机播放之类的操作，对吧？你只能从头听到尾。音质看起来还可以，我其实并不是在那种
where i could tell if it was a really high quality stream or not but it seemed okay um and people were saying like that i guess a version a version, I didn't quite follow, but a version have, a pirated but lower quality version had been, like, put onto the torrent sites right before this. It's like people were confused, like, did they steal it from the streaming site or something? And it turns out now, like, this happened a couple days ago that they released the streaming version. Somebody did find a way to basically anytime iTunes does this, you can go download it from the stream. Basically, they're just streaming a file.
能分辨出是不是高质量流媒体的环境下听的，但它看起来还可以。人们在说，我猜有一个版本，一个版本，我没太听懂，但是有一个版本，一个盗版但音质较低的版本，在这一切发生之前就被放到了种子网站上。就像人们很困惑，他们是从流媒体网站上偷的吗？结果现在，几天前他们发布了流媒体版本，有人确实找到了一种方法，基本上任何时候 iTunes 这样做，你都可以从流媒体中下载。基本上，他们只是在流式传输一个文件。
So you can find a link to that file, basically, and then just download it. Or, of course, you could always just record it. Yeah, just capture the audio. But it's interesting because if you're going to do that hassle, like, presumably you would probably download it somewhere else anyways. But it's interesting to try to maybe get more people to buy it they'll do this i mean i from my impression daft punk has more money than they care to what to do with so like i don't like i don't know that they super care like if people steal their album or not which may be different for small people but this is kind of an interesting move to head off you know people trying to release earlier get the scoop
所以你基本上可以找到指向该文件的链接，然后直接下载。或者，当然，你总是可以录制它。是的，只需捕获音频。但这很有趣，因为如果你要做这种麻烦事，大概你无论如何也会去别的地方下载。但为了让更多人买单，他们会这么做，这挺有意思的。我的印象是，蠢朋克拥有的钱比他们操心的还多，所以我不觉得他们超级在乎别人是否偷他们的专辑，这对于小人物来说可能有所不同，但这算是一个有趣的举动，可以阻止人们试图提前发布、抢先报道。
yeah there was a ted talk about a lady who, you know, going back to your point about big versus, like, small artists, she, from day one, made all of her albums free and did everything off donations and merch sales at her concert. And she did remarkably well. So, like, the studies show that if you release all the music for free, more people will come to your concert, and enough of those people will buy t-shirts and bracelets or especially she kind of you know like she'd make it a point in her concert to be like you know hey if you like it you
是的，有一个关于一位女士的 TED 演讲，回到你关于大牌与小独立音乐人的观点，她从第一天起就将她所有的专辑都免费提供，一切都靠捐赠和演唱会上的周边销售。她做得非常成功。所以，研究表明，如果你把所有的音乐都免费发布，更多的人会来到你的演唱会，其中足够多的人会购买T恤和手镯，或者尤其是她那种，你知道的，她会在演唱会上特意说：“嘿，如果你喜欢它，
know pay money for something you know yeah please support us a little bit of psychology there you have to do kind of the right thing there but uh but yeah it worked really well for her yeah i think it's music industry is probably going to break into pieces where different people earn living in different ways or whatever. But I have heard this story over and over again that, yeah, if you kind of just give it away for free and then charge for your concert and for merchandise, you can do pretty well. But it's increasingly difficult to charge for the music itself.
你知道的，为某些东西付点钱，你知道的，是的，请支持我们。”这里面有一点心理学。你必须在那里做正确的事情，但……是的，这对她很管用。是的，我认为音乐产业可能会四分五裂，不同的人以不同的方式谋生。但我一遍又一遍地听到这个故事，是的，如果你只是把它免费送出去，然后为你的演唱会和周边收费，你就可以做得很好。但为音乐本身收费却越来越困难。
And people are saying with increasing, with increasing, like, this, you know, RDO and Spotify, and then recently Google announced they were going to be doing something similar. It's rumored Apple's going to do something similar as well, these, like, radio things. But they pay ridiculously low. Like, it's like 100 streams of your song, and you'll get three pennies or something.
人们说随着越来越……随着这样的增多，你知道的，Rdio 和 Spotify，然后最近谷歌宣布他们也将做类似的事情。有传言称苹果也会做类似的事情，这些像广播一样的东西。但他们支付的报酬低得离谱。比如你的歌被播放 100 次，你只能得到三分钱左右。
Yeah, exactly. It's like some ridiculously bad deal. So, like, charging for that is really, really hard. Yep. And it makes sense that the concert, even when people were paying, say, $1 a song on iTunes, that's still nothing compared to $70 a ticket to go to a concert. If you go to a concert, you're probably going to have to bring a friend, right?
对，没错。这就像是个糟透了的糟糕交易。所以，收取费用真的非常非常难。是的。而且这就说得通了，演唱会，即使当人们在 iTunes 上为一首歌支付 1 美元时，与去看演唱会的 70 美元门票相比，这仍然算不了什么。如果你去演唱会，你可能得带一个朋友，对吧？
Unless you want to go alone. So that's like $140 they're making. But it's not it's not scalable right i mean ideally you would like to be able to sell your album digitally all over the world with basically no cost versus if you do a concert you have to pay to rent the venue you have to go there you can only do it for so that's a good point i saw there's and i forgot the name of it now but there's some artists are doing like concerts online Where like you can pay like five dollars or whatever and like watch them play a couple of songs
除非你想一个人去。所以他们赚的差不多是 140 美元。但这不可扩展，对吧？我的意思是，理想情况下，你希望能够在世界各地以几乎零成本数字售卖你的专辑，而如果你办演唱会，你必须付钱租场地，你必须去那里，你只能为……所以这是一个好点子。我看到，我忘了它叫什么名字了，但有些艺术家在网上办演唱会，你可以付五美元左右，然后看他们弹唱几首歌。
I'm like, you know like YouTube like YouTube like as opposed to recording a video or streaming it live though You like people buy to like have you play or whatever. I thought that was kind of interesting, you know, like okay You know, that's another way to do it like a more quote-unquote intimate setting i guess like with only the really diehard fans it's like what udacity is to colleges they're trying to do concerts yes maybe okay i don't know that that point escapes me yep okay but uh yeah another article is pretty interesting. North Carolina has banned. So technically they haven't banned Teslas, but they've effectively banned. Well, Tesla sales. Right, but they've effectively banned Tesla sales. Basically, so apparently to have a car dealership, you have to meet a bunch of criteria. And one of the criteria is you have to be in the state and employed in the state, things like that.
就像，你知道的，像 YouTube 吗？就像 YouTube 那样，而不是录制视频或进行直播，不过你让人家付费看你弹奏或者什么的。我觉得这挺有趣的，你知道的，就像，好吧，你知道，那是另一种方式，比如一种更可以说是私密的设置，我猜只有那些最铁杆的粉丝。这就好比 Udacity 对大学的影响，他们正试图举办演唱会。是的，也许吧，好吧，我不懂那个梗，好吧。不过，嗯，还有另一篇挺有趣的文章。北卡罗来纳州已经禁止了。所以严格来说他们并没有禁止特斯拉，但他们实际上已经禁止了。好吧，特斯拉的销售。没错，但他们实际上已经禁止了特斯拉的销售。基本上，显然要经营一家汽车经销商，你必须满足一堆标准。其中一个标准就是你必须在该州并在该州受雇，诸如此类。
So, you know, there's a lot of, for example, if you go to your neighborhood, you know, Ford or Cadillac, whatever dealership, they have, you know, a general manager for that dealership who lives in that state, etc. And they have a set of certified car salesmen, etc. So Tesla didn't want to do any of that. They wanted to sort of take a page from Apple's textbook and just have a bunch of stores with a couple of cars and then some Tesla geniuses, like the Apple geniuses, but they would really kind of route you through either a phone or an online system
所以，你知道的，有很多，例如，如果你去你附近的福特或凯迪拉克或其他任何经销商，他们在那家经销商那里有一位住在该州的总经理，等等。他们有一套经过认证的汽车销售人员，等等。所以特斯拉不想做任何这些。他们想从苹果的教科书中借鉴一页，只开一堆只有几辆车的商店，然后有一些特斯拉天才，就像苹果天才一样，但他们实际上会通过电话或在线系统引导你
or something like that, and you'd custom order your car, et etc so um they're going that route and uh you know anytime you go against you know the status quo you're going to run up against people with a lot of money and they're for a lot of resistance and so apparently there was uh some lobbyists who gave the senator of North Carolina a bunch of money and he passed a law, pushed through a law saying that, no, if you don't have a certified dealership, you can't sell cars in our state. Yeah, it's a really subtle issue where there are established car dealerships. And I guess the way these things are currently written,
或者类似的东西，然后你定制你的汽车，等等。所以，嗯，他们走的是那条路线，而且，你知道，任何时候你违背现状，你都会遇到很多有钱人，因此会有很多阻力。所以显然有一些说客给了北卡罗来纳州参议员一大笔钱，然后他通过了一项法律，推动通过了一项法律，说不，如果你没有认证的经销商，你就不能在我们州卖车。是的，这是一个非常微妙的问题，那里有老牌汽车经销商。我猜这些事情目前的写法，
like I think you're alluding to, it's like the people who make cars aren't allowed to sell directly to a consumer. Right. For whatever, you know, probably I'm sure I'm going to trust that was a legitimate reason at one point about why you would want to buy from someone else as opposed to directly from the people who made the car. This whole infrastructure was created. And like I said, I'm sure there are legitimate reasons. I just don't know what they are. I don't know. But Tesla now, right, is trying to skip that.
就像你暗指的那样，制造汽车的人不允许直接卖给消费者。对。不管出于什么，你知道的，我敢肯定在某个时候有一个合理的理由，说明为什么你想从其他人那里购买，而不是直接从制造汽车的人那里购买。整个基础设施就是这样建立的。就像我说的，我确信有合理的理由。我只是不知道是什么。我不知道。但特斯拉现在，对吧，正试图跳过这一步。
Like, oh, we don't want middlemen. We just want to sell directly and like help lower costs. In addition to all the other things they're doing with making the electric car and all that. This is one of the ways they're trying to be different. And so, like you said, just have, it's just a showroom, but not actually a dealership kind of thing.
就像，哦，我们不想要中间商。我们只想直接销售并帮助降低成本。除了他们在制造电动汽车方面所做的所有其他事情之外。这是他们试图与众不同的方式之一。所以，就像你说的，只是有，它只是一个展厅，而不是实际的经销商那种东西。
And then people just kind of thing and then people just kind of buy from tesla directly in california right and then you know they just bring the car to them or whatever it's like it's like amazon like you just buy your car in amazon and they just deliver it to your door yeah it just shows up but that you want somewhere to go sit in the car and try it or whatever presumably right but like you said this makes a lot of established people very upset um it's kind of nerve-wracking though that like they're not just trying to hurt tesla but they're also concerned like mayor maybe or maybe not they're concerned about tesla but i think there's also like some other thing where maybe they're concerned about ford saying wow this works really
然后人们就直接从加州的特斯拉购买，然后，你知道的，他们只是把车运给他们或者别的什么。这就像亚马逊一样，你只是在亚马逊上买车，然后他们把它送到你家门口。是的，它就出现了。但你希望有个地方可以去坐在车里试驾或者别的什么，大概是吧。但就像你说的，这让很多老牌车企非常不高兴。不过，这有点让人紧张，他们不仅想伤害特斯拉，他们也担心——也许是，也许不是——他们担心特斯拉，但我觉得还有其他事情，也许他们担心福特会说：“哇，这对特斯拉很管用，对我们也会很管用。”然后福特开始直接在北卡罗来纳州销售。他们绕过了……他们的售价可以比其他人更便宜，因为他们不需要维持库存。你是在网上买车的吗？没有。好吧。好吧，我没有在网上买车。我在网上货比三家。
well for tesla it would work really good for us too. And then Ford starts selling directly in North Carolina. And they bypass the, they can sell cheaper than these other people can because they don't have to hold inventory. You bought your car online or no? No. Okay. Well, I haven't bought my car online. I shopped for it online.
就像我到处看，发邮件给别人。所以我最终去了某个地方买下了它。确实有可能，对吧，上网完全定制你想要的汽车，然后……然后它去到商店。我的意思是，不，我觉得最终你还是得通过经销商。哦，我明白了。就像你不能……至少据我所知，我不觉得你可以去福特官网——我们继续用福特作为例子——但去福特的网站上，挑一辆车，然后说，你知道，我只想直接按这个价格把所有的钱都付了，（把支票寄给他们，或者随便什么，然后让它出现在你家门口。）好吧。
Like I did a lot of shopping around and, you know, emailing people. So ultimately I went somewhere and bought it. It is possible, right, to go online and totally customize the car you want online and then and then it goes to the store i mean like no i think ultimately you have to go through a dealership oh i see like you can't have at least i know of i don't think like you can go on ford's we just keep using ford as an example but yeah go on ford's website like pick out a car and say like you know i want to just go ahead and pay for all of this at this price you know send your check to just go ahead and pay for all of this at this price you know send your check to them or whatever and have it show up to your door okay
或者甚至就像让它出现在某个地方，对吧？就像我觉得最终你可以订购它，但然后我觉得发生的事情——至少这是我做的一点点功课得出的假设——你可以建造你想要的汽车，但最终他们会说，这是你所在地区的五家经销商，你想让哪一家给你一个关于这辆车要花多少钱的报价？比如他们会向你收取多少费用。我明白了。好吧。对吧？
or even like have it just show up to somewhere right like i think ultimately you can order it but then i think what happens at least this is my assumption from the little bit of stuff i did you can build the car you want but then ultimately they say here's five dealers in your area which one would you like to get you a quote on what that car will cost? Like how much they'll charge you for it. I see. Okay. Right?
所以他们有点像，这是标价，但那个价格真的很高。就像你永远不会真的想付那个价格一样。哦，我明白了。所以他们会打电话给你，然后，哦，我们可以给你比这更好的优惠。你知道，或者可能只是向你收费。这只是取决于情况。明白了。是的。
So they kind of have like, here's the listed price, but that price is really high. Like you wouldn't ever really want to pay that price. Oh, I see. So then like they call you and like, oh, we can give you a better deal than that. You know, or maybe just charge you. That just depends. Gotcha. Yeah.
我觉得没有，没有像……但说得通，对吧？对我来说，我宁愿根据评论挑选汽车并定制它，然后让某人开着平板卡车把它送到我家，然后有一天把它卸下来。所以汽车有点不同，我想与大多数事情不同的是，你知道，买车时你必须进行谈判。就像我买烤面包机时不谈判，对吧？但是，是的，所以，但是，好吧，所以房子是一笔巨大的投资。而且房屋供应也有限。所以这一点有点不同。但即使像买一台巨大的电视。
I don't think there's no like but makes sense right like for me i would rather just like pick the car based on reviews and like customize it and then just have somebody drive it on a flatbed to my house right and drop it off one day like so so cars are a little different i think than most things in that you know you you have to sort of negotiate when you're buying a car like i don't negotiate when I'm buying a toaster, right? But yeah, so, but okay, so a house is a huge investment. And also there's limited supply of houses. So there it's a little bit different. But even like take a huge TV.
假设你想买一台巨大的 6000 美元的电视。有些车的价格是 6000 美元，对吧？所以有些起亚汽车我敢肯定那个价格，总之，对吧？所以是的，理论上有些起亚汽车，我敢肯定它们的价格，总之，重点是，有些东西花了很多钱但不涉及谈判。所以我感觉那种汽车谈判、去找销售人员讨价还价的事情可以消失。我感觉不到……所以我觉得，我同意，我不喜欢那个方面。事实上，你知道，我差一点……有一家经销商说：“看，我们不知道怎么搞的，这就是我们的价格。”他们不是在开玩笑。
Let's say you wanna buy a gigantic $6,000 TV. There's some cars that cost 6,000, right? So there's some Kias out there I'm sure that cost, anyway, right so yes there's some theoretically some kios out there i'm sure they cost anyway the point is there's there's things that cost a lot of money that don't involve negotiation right and so i feel like the whole like car negotiating go to the salesman and haggle thing like that can disappear like i don't feel so i feel i i agree i don't like that aspect in fact i you know i almost went there was one dealership we had which just said like look We don't know good like this is our price and they weren't like, you know joking
就像我感觉他们真的不打算和我谈判，但他们的价格也真的非常好。但后来不幸的是，尽管我不想让这发生，但结果可能更好，我去找了其他人，他们不相信我，直到我说出另一家店提供的价格，但他们真的设法把它卖得更便宜了，所以我当时想，哦，我宁愿把生意交给那家不让我谈判的地方，而且从各方面来看，它似乎是最好的交易，但后来我确实设法在别处谈成了一个更好的交易。这感觉有点像，哦……但我确实认为，汽车是你购买的最昂贵的东西之一。
Like I got the sense like legitimately they had no intention to negotiate with me, but their price is also really really good But then unfortunately as much as I didn't want this to happen, but it ended up better I guess I went and found other people who didn't believe me Until I said like like what this other place was was offering but then they actually did manage to give it to me cheaper and so i was like oh i'd rather give my business to the place that wasn't gonna make me negotiate and was giving me what from all intents and purposes seemed like the best deal but then i did manage to negotiate a better deal somewhere else it's kind of like oh but i do think like i mean cars are one of the most expensive things you would buy
而且我也认为，我以前不知道这一点，但如果你愿意谈判，你其实不能在购买电视时进行谈判……你不能……你可以在购买电视时进行谈判。对，所以如果你要买那么贵的东西，你完全可以……甚至就像从低端开始，你也可以货比三家。
and I also think which increasingly I didn't know this but if you're willing to negotiate you can't actually negotiate on TV purchases you can't do what you can negotiate on TV purchases yeah so like if you're going to buy something that expensive you can well even just like from a low level you could shop around
对，就像你去弗莱电子（Fry's）或百思买（Best Buy）或者……哦，对，无论如何，你可以货比三家，对吧？你可以带上一则广告，对吧？就像，嘿，他们卖得更便宜。你能给我比这更好的优惠吗？然后另一件事是，汽车通常不只是标准商品。有很多选项，对吧？所以如果是电视，你可以做到这一点，对吧？
right like you go to Fry's or Best Buy or oh yeah definitely whatever you could shop around, right? Like you go to Fry's or Best Buy or whatever. You could bring an ad, right? Like, hey, they got it cheaper. Like, can you give me a better deal than this? And then the other thing is cars are typically not just like a standard item. There's a lot of options, right? So if there's like a TV, you could do that, right?
如果你开始加入延长保修期以及它是否带有安装套件之类的东西，你尤其可以在这些部分进行谈判。是的，其实你提醒了我，抱歉打断你，专家小贴士：如果你在买新手机，你几乎总是可以免费得到一个手机壳。我买过去两三部手机都送了免费手机壳，因为我只是说，看，这个价格挺高的，你知道的，我可能可以买到更便宜的，你知道的，走出店门，第二天再来，你就能得到一个免费手机壳。所以不管这对我来说是否值得，但是的，正如你所说，你可以在很多事情上谈判。
Like if you start to include things like extended warranties and like whether it comes with an installation kit and stuff like you can especially negotiate on those parts yeah actually you just reminded me sorry to interject pro tip if you're getting a new phone you can almost always get a free case so the past two or three phones of paid for I've got free cases just because I just say look this price it's pretty high you know i could probably get it cheaper you know walk out the store come back the next day you get a free case so whether that is like worth it to you or not but yeah to your point you can
是的，所以我想我们……也许这是我们这一代人，也许这只是我们的个性，我不知道这是什么，但我个人其实不太喜欢谈判。就像，我宁愿大家都开诚布公，好吧，这永远不会发生。但是，你知道的，我真的不太喜欢那样。但我确实知道，有时如果你愿意说出某些话，这以前发生在我身上。有几次我甚至只是提了一下。比如，哦，我看到，你们在另一件商品上提供了这个东西或别的什么。我能在这件商品上也享受这个吗？我当时想，好吧，当然。他们就会给我提供这个东西或其他东西或者折扣，或者，哦，这张优惠券过期了。我能继续使用它吗？实际上，他们真的不应该给你，因为促销活动是跟优惠券绑定的，所以他们尽量不同时进行促销和使用优惠券，诸如此类的事情。但如果你只是问，然后他们说可以，
negotiate on a lot of things yeah so like i think we maybe it's our generation maybe it's just who we are i don't i have no idea what it is but I personally don't really care for negotiation. Like, I'd rather just be, everybody be up front, which, okay, which never happens. But, like, you know, I don't really like doing that. But I do know that sometimes if you're willing to say something, like this happened to me before. A couple times I've, you know, just mentioned something even. Like, oh, I saw, like, you guys offered this thing or whatever on this other item. Could I get it on this? I'm like, yeah, sure. And they'll give me offer this thing or whatever on this other item. Could I get it on this? And they're like, yeah, sure.
无论是因为他们不知道自己在做什么，还是他们真的很想做成这笔生意，所有事情都有很大的回旋余地。这题跑题太远了。不过我真的希望有一天我能直接上网，选择我想要的东西，得到一个公平的价格，然后把车送到我家。是的，这就对了。然后只需要处理谈判和卖掉我以前的车。是的，我觉得我们可以做到这一点，我的意思是这是一个朝着正确方向迈出的步伐。除非它到处都被禁止。等等，这是朝着错误方向迈出的步伐。北卡罗来纳州禁止了它。
And they'll give me some other thing or a discount or, oh, this coupon expired. Could I go ahead and use it anyways? And in reality, they really shouldn't give it to you because sales are tied to coupons, so they try not to run sales and coupons at the same time and this kind of thing. But if you just ask and then they say okay,
是的，这篇文章是朝着错误方向迈出的一步。不过，是的，我的意思是，最终，你知道，汽车会……互联网上已经有这么多的信息了，对吧？你可以去一家经销商。如果你能在试驾时把车开到 CarMax 尝试卖掉它，那就太棒了。哦。是的。我们把这个话题扯得太远了。你见过那个人的故事吗？他说他可以击败世界上任何国际象棋棋手，甚至是特级大师，只要他挑出其中两个，他就能保证击败其中一个。他只要来回走对方走过的那一步棋就行了。哦，不，我没听过这个故事。是的，所以假设有两个特级大师。对，对，对。有两个特级大师。你说，哦，对，对，对。你只是让他们两个互相博弈。
either because they don't know what they're doing or they just really want to make the sale, there's a lot of wiggle room for all all things that was a far off topic i would i really do on the day though where i can just like go online choose what i want get a fair price and like have the car brought to my house yeah that's all it makes and then only have to deal with negotiating and selling my car my previous car yeah i think that we we can get there i mean this is a step in the right direction. Unless it gets banned everywhere. Wait, this is a step in the wrong direction. North Carolina banning it.
只要一个人执白，另一个执黑，那么，是的，你只要走对方走的那一步，最终你就能击败其中一个，对吧？是的，好吧。如果你能用纸牌做到这一点就好了。好吧，我没有……好吧，也许这有点极端。但我的意思是，是的，走着瞧吧。我不知道我们是否能走到那一步。
Yeah, the article is a step in the wrong direction. But yeah, I mean, eventually, you know, cars will, you know, there's already so much information on the internet, right? That you could go to a dealership. It would be amazing if you could take a car and on the test drive, take it to CarMax and try and sell it. Oh. Yeah. We're dragging this topic out. Have you seen that story from the person who, he said he could beat any chess player
这很有趣。而且这也是困难的，因为……我们偏题了，但这里有整个自由市场的问题，对吧？但随后人们想改变它的本质，比如，哦，特斯拉正在获得不公平的优势或别的什么，我们希望他们在同一起跑线上。当人们在玩游戏并且玩得很好时，他们不希望游戏规则改变，对吧？这倒也是。所以，嗯，我觉得有些事情挺有意思的，当你看到这一点时，就好像，真的是这样吗？这太公然了，你只是在拼命保护你的既得利益，不允许事情发生改变。是的，是的，这绝对是这里正在发生的事情。我不知道，不管怎样，我们刚才真的跑题了。
in the world, even a grandmaster, as long as he picks two of them, he can guarantee to beat one of them. And he would just go back and forth playing the move the other one played. Oh, no, I haven't heard this story. Yeah, so let's say there's two grandmasters. Yeah, yeah, yeah. there's two grandmasters. You say, oh yeah, yeah, yeah. You just play them off each other.
相当远，所以是时候进入本期工具环节了。哦，我刚才说重影了，哇，混响工具，我甚至不需要在后期制作中这样做。好吧，你先来。好吧，我先来。所以我本期推荐的工具是 TypeScript。所以 JavaScript。那就是你输入脚本的地方。为什么我每次都忍不住在你说这话时做一些愚蠢的评论？这真的很烦人。
As long as one plays white and the other plays black, then yeah, you just play the other move and eventually you beat one of them, right? Yeah, okay. It'd be nice if you could do this with cards. Okay, I didn't, okay, maybe that's a little bit extreme. But I mean, yeah, we'll see. I don't know if we'll ever get there.
对不起。那是书法。不。所以 JavaScript 无处不在，对吧？我的意思是，你知道，JavaScript 是唯一在所有主流浏览器上都能运行的语言。所以如果你要在浏览器中做客户端的事情，你就要编写 JavaScript。现在，JavaScript，苹果和谷歌并不太合得来，所以谁也不想支持对方。就像，你知道，苹果不支持 Java，编程 Java。
It's interesting. And it's also hard because, we're getting off topic, but there's this whole free market aspect, right right but then people want to change what that is like oh tesla is getting you know unfair advantage or whatever we want them to play on the same field people don't want the game to change when they're playing a game and doing good at it right that's true so um i think there's some things it's kind of interesting when you see this and it's like really like this is kind of blatant that like you're just trying to protect your entrenchment and not allowing things to change yeah yeah that's definitely what's going on here i don't know anyways we're that was way off topic
谷歌不支持用于 Android 的 Objective-C。Windows，我甚至不知道你写什么，也不支持 Java，编程 Java。谷歌不支持用于 Android 的 Objective-C。Windows，我甚至不知道你写什么。我猜还有 C#，谁知道呢。但我知道的一件事是，它们都支持 JavaScript 编译器。所以，你知道，如果你试图把 Java 编译器，你知道的，用 C++ 写的，比如那个编译器，作为你应用的一部分提交到苹果商店，他们会直接拒绝它。这种事以前发生过。
quite a bit so time for tool of the show show show oh i did double there wow reverb tool and i didn't even have to do that in post so all. All right, you're up first. All right, I'm up first. So my tool of the show is TypeScript. So JavaScript. That's where you type out scripts. Why do I always, I'm so compelled every time to make some stupid comment when you say this? It's really annoying.
人们尝试过。他们一次又一次被拒绝。但 JavaScript 编译器是完全合法的。所以 JavaScript 接管了移动端，原因和它接管桌面端的原因一样，那就是，你知道的，它支持所有主流手机。所以随着 JavaScript 变得如此受欢迎，人们一直试图……你知道……试图两全其美，试图使用 JavaScript 并获得这种通用的支持，但同时也试图获得诸如类型安全之类的东西。
I'm sorry. It's calligraphy. No. So JavaScript is totally ubiquitous, right? I mean, you know, JavaScript's the only language that works on all major browsers. So if you're going to do something client-side in the browser, you're going to be writing JavaScript. Now JavaScript, so Apple and Google don't quite get along, so neither one wants to support the other one. Like, you know, Apple doesn't support Java, programming Java.
诸如静态分析之类的东西，如果你在使用比方说 C++ 或 Java 之类的话，这些东西会让生活变得容易得多。听过我们很多期节目的听众都知道我们对此进行了详细的讨论。长话短说，TypeScript 是 JavaScript 的一种方言，但它允许你用类型来注释 JavaScript。你可以说，嘿，这个东西永远只能是一个整数，那个东西永远只能是一个字符串，等等。然后会发生什么呢，你运行一个 TypeScript 编译器，它获取所有这些注释，它还支持一些很酷的东西，比如类和继承，诸如此类。它获取你所有的 TypeScript 文件并将它们转换为 JavaScript，它将它们转译（transpile）。
Google doesn't support Objective-C for Android. Windows, I don't even know what you write, and I't support Java, programming Java. Google doesn't support Objective-C for Android. Windows, I don't even know what you write. And I guess C Sharp, who knows. But one thing I do know is that all of them support the JavaScript compiler. So, you know, if you were to try to submit the Java compiler, you know, in C++, like that compiler, as part of your app to the iPhone store, they will just reject it. And this has happened before.
当它这样做时，它不会创建你所期望的那种可怕的 JavaScript，就像某种彻底的灾难一样。但它创建的 JavaScript 实际上非常易读。在此过程中，它确保你没有违反任何类型约束。所以这挺酷的。我一直在使用它一点点。
People have tried. They've been rejected over and over. But the JavaScript compiler, totally legit. So JavaScript has taken over mobile for the same reason that it's taken over desktop, which is, you know, it supports all the major phones so with JavaScript becoming so popular people have been trying to sort of you know cut try to get the best of both worlds try to use JavaScript and and get this your universal you know support but then also try to get things like type safety
我还没用它做过什么东西。但我一直在使用这个 Turbulence TypeScript 游戏引擎，我真的很喜欢它。我是它的超级粉丝。不错，不错。那么它和我听说的其他东西有很大不同吗，比如那些 JavaScript 的衍生品？是的，所以有 CoffeeScript。
things like static analysis these things which make life a lot easier if you're doing, say, C++ or Java or something like that. And people have listened to a lot of our episodes know that we talk about this at length. So long story short, TypeScript is a dialect of JavaScript, but it allows you to annotate JavaScript with types. You're allowed to say, hey, this thing should only ever be an integer, and this thing should only ever be a string, et cetera. So then what happens, you run a TypeScript compiler, which takes all of these annotations, and it also supports some cool things like classes and inheritance, things like that. It takes all of your TypeScript files and converts them into JavaScript, and it transpiles them.
是的，CoffeeScript，Dart。还有 Dart。所以 TypeScript 的一个酷炫之处在于，正如我提到的，它是一种注释系统。所以你可以采用现有的 JavaScript 代码，只需将文件重命名为 .ts。然后 TypeScript 会将它们编译回 JavaScript，在这种情况下这是一个空操作（no-op）。但你可以拿一个现有的 JavaScript 项目，它立刻就成了一个 TypeScript 项目。对我来说这很有吸引力，或者实际上当我阅读他们的博客时，这对 Turbulence 的开发者来说很有吸引力。
And when it does, it doesn't create some horrendous JavaScript that you would expect, like just some complete disaster. But it creates JavaScript that's actually very readable. And along the way, it makes sure that you haven't violated any of your type constraints. So it's pretty cool. I've been using it a little bit.
他们说，你知道，我们有大量的 JavaScript 代码，我们遇到了所有这些运行时错误，这有点一团糟，无法维护。我们需要一种方法来添加类型安全和其他好东西，但我们又不想从头重写代码。所以，是的，Dart 相当棒。绝对可以去了解一下。我们谈论过 Dart 吗？我不知道。我想我们做过一期节目。
I haven't made anything with it. But I've been using this Turbulence TypeScript game engine, and I'm really liking it. I'm a big fan. Nice, nice. So is it much different than other things I hear, which are like JavaScript derivative stuff? Yeah, so there's CoffeeScript.
是的，我们做过一期关于 Dart 的节目。好吧。我们记性真差。好吧，这是我们的第 27 期节目。他们说人类只能记住七件事。我们会在我们的 AI 电影中讨论这个。但无论如何。哦，我们确实讨论过。我们在我们的 AI 电影里讨论过那个。但无论如何。哦，我们确实。
Yeah, CoffeeScript, Dart. There's Dart. So one cool thing about TypeScript is, as I mentioned, kind of an annotation system. So you can take existing JavaScript code and just rename the files to.ts. And then TypeScript will compile them back to JavaScript, which is a no-op in this case. But you can take an existing JavaScript project, and it immediately is a TypeScript project. That was kind of the appeal for me, or actually the appeal for this Turbulence developers when I was reading their blog.
我们做了一整期关于 Dart 的节目。天哪，我现在觉得自己好蠢。是的。所以有很多语言。哦，我记起来了，是的。TypeScript 挺不错的，因为它就是 JavaScript。至少它可以是。所以，是的。
They said, you know, we had a ton of JavaScript code, we were getting all these runtime errors and it's kind of a mess and unmaintainable. And we needed a way to sort of add type safety and other nice things, but we didn't want to rewrite our code from scratch. So, yeah, Dart is pretty awesome. Definitely look into that. Have we talked about Dart? I don't know. I think we did a show on it.
酷。那么你本期推荐的工具是什么？任何想在家一起玩的人可以去听第 12 期。哦，是的。闪回时刻。你可以去听我们那时谈论 Dart。不，我记得谈论过 Dart。
Yeah, we did a show on Dart. Okay. We have terrible memory. Well, it's our 27th show. They say humans can only remember seven things. We'll talk about that in our AI movie. But anyways. Oh, we did. We did talk about that in our AI movie. But anyways. Oh, we did.
我只是想了解其中的区别，因为我以前没听说过 TypeScript。明白了。试图将新事物与我所知道的事物联系起来。不错。你知道的，Java 只是带有垃圾回收的 C++。这就是我对 Java 的理解。当然。
We did a whole show on Dart. Man, I feel stupid now. Yes. So there's a bunch of languages. Oh, I remember now, yes. TypeScript is pretty nice because it is JavaScript. At least it can be. So yeah.
还有电池。抱歉。那不是个好笑的笑话。鉴于我一直不擅长坚持使用真正有用的工具，我又带来了一款游戏。它们是你心灵的工具。它们是我消磨时间的工具。是的。
Cool. So what is your tool-ish show? That was episode 12 for anybody wanting to play along at home. Oh, yeah. Definitely. Flashback time. You can go listen to us talk about Dart then. No, I remember talking about Dart.
而且我觉得更糟糕的是，我觉得这个是 iOS 专属的，那就是《荒诞钓鱼》（Ridiculous Fishing）。荒诞。所以《荒诞钓鱼》真的是荒诞无比，游戏一开始你基本上是渔船上的一个人，但它不像那些老游戏，如果你玩过那种带有小小手持鱼竿的游戏，你甩一下然后卷线，或者别的什么——我不记得它们叫什么了。哦，对，我记得就像《巴斯职业钓鱼》（Bass Pro）之类的，对，对，对。所以它不像那样，它要荒诞得多。
I just was trying to understand the difference because I haven't heard of TypeScript before. Gotcha. To try to relate something new to something I know. Nice. You know, Java is just C++ with garbage collection. That's how I understand Java. Sure.
我只是想了解一下区别，因为我以前没听说过 TypeScript。明白了。就是想把新东西和我已知的东西联系起来。不错。你知道的，Java 其实就是带垃圾回收的 C++。我是这么理解 Java 的。当然。
And batteries. Sorry. That was not a funny joke. In my continued not doing good at sticking to actual things that are useful as tools, I have another game. They're tools for your mind. They're tools for me to spend time. Yeah.
还有电池。抱歉。这个笑话一点也不好笑。由于我一直不太擅长坚持使用真正有用的工具，我又带来了一款游戏。它们是滋养心灵的工具。它们是我用来消磨时间的工具。是的。
And I think actually worse, I think this one is iOS specific, and that is Ridiculous Fishing. Ridiculous. So Ridiculous F fishing is truly ridiculous um the game starts out as you're basically a guy on a fishing boat but it's not like one of those old games if you ever played one like with the little uh handheld fishing rod you like flick it and you like wind or whatever like i don't remember what they were called oh yeah i remember like bass pro yeah or something yeah yeah yeah so it's not like that though it's it's much more ridiculous
而且我觉得更糟糕的是，这款游戏似乎是 iOS 专属的，那就是《Ridiculous Fishing》（疯狂捕鱼）。太荒谬了。所以《Ridiculous Fishing》真的很荒谬，嗯……游戏一开始，你基本上是渔船上的一个渔夫，但它不像那些老游戏——如果你玩过那种带有小小手持鱼竿的游戏，比如轻轻一甩然后卷线什么的——我不记得那些叫什么了。哦，对，我记得像什么《Bass Pro》或者别的什么。对，对，对。所以它可不是那样的，它要荒谬得多。
so you you cast your lure into the water but there's no casting mechanism you just drop it and it starts to fall through the water column and there are fish but you're really trying to avoid the fish oh because you want to get down because good fish are like lower so you want to get down like not it's like different types of fish versus like each type only has one size but anyway you like navigate your way down trying to avoid fish and the first fish you ran run into you're gonna hook him and then you start coming up but on the way up any fish you hit you also hook so kind of like catamari would I be like getting bigger and bigger clump of fish on your hook oh man but doesn't grow so like you but anyways it does okay you're
所以你，你把鱼钩抛进水里，但这里没有抛竿机制，你只是放手让它开始顺着水层往下沉，那里有鱼，但你其实极力想要避开这些鱼，哦，因为你想下潜，因为好鱼都在更深的地方，所以你想下潜，不同种类的鱼其实每种只有一个尺寸，但不管怎样，你一路往下导航，试图避开鱼，而你碰到的第一条鱼就会被你钩住，然后你开始往上收线，但在上浮的途中，你撞到的任何鱼也都会被钩住，有点像块魂游戏（Katamari），我的意思是，你的鱼钩上会积聚越来越大的一团鱼，哦天哪，但它不会变大，所以就像你，但不管怎样，它会……好吧，你
so you're sending now through the water column the opposite of however far down you went and that would be pretty ridiculous because it's got like a crazy vector art style and pixel but it doesn't stop there oh okay as soon as you get to the surface instead of having collected those fish you don't actually get the fish until you shoot them so the fish explode into like a a rain of fish and then you have to take your finger on the touch screen and tap the fish to shoot them and some fish take you have to shoot multiple times some fish are negative points you actually don't want to shoot them or you lose points so you shoot all the fish as they're raining
所以你现在正穿过水层往回送，也就是你下潜距离的反向，那将相当荒谬，因为它的艺术风格就像是疯狂的矢量图加像素风，但它还不止于此，哦，好吧，一旦你浮到水面，你收集的那些鱼并不是直接到手，直到你射击它们之前你其实都得不到这些鱼，所以这些鱼会爆炸成一场鱼雨，然后你必须用手指在触摸屏上点击这些鱼来射击它们，有些鱼你得射击多次，有些鱼是负分，你其实不想射击它们，否则你会失分，所以当鱼如下雨般落下时你要射击所有的鱼
up and then down uh and then any ones you miss fall into the water and you lose them you know it doesn't count so do you get one cast and then you started like you see cast a different game a different instance of the game yeah yeah basically so I get then so once this thing is done then it's over right like you have gotten some money and then you can buy upgrades so like things that allow you to not have to go back up the first time you have fish kind of like a health or whatever you know or like a better lure that allows you to chainsaw through fish and score points that way or like better guns so like maybe like a orbiting laser cannon that blows fish up or
向上，然后向下，呃，接着任何你漏掉的鱼都会落入水中，你就会失去它们，你知道的，这不算数，所以你抛竿一次，然后你开始像，你看，抛进另一个游戏，游戏的另一个实例，是啊，是啊，基本上就是这样，所以我得到了，一旦这件事情完成，那就结束了，对吧？就像你已经赚了一些钱，然后你可以购买升级，比如那些让你不用第一次就得浮上水面的东西，有点像生命值或者别的什么，你知道的，或者像一个更好的鱼钩，让你能用链锯锯开鱼并通过这种方式得分，或者像更好的武器，比如也许是一个在轨道上运行的激光炮，能把鱼炸飞，或者
maybe a shotgun or a machine gun and like depending on your style to the bottom is there a yeah so there's different uh fishing holes you go to, and they have different depths, and there are different things at the bottom. And there's a progression and a story, and an end, and I won't spoil it, but it's a ridiculous story that I don't think I really understand.
也许是霰弹枪或机枪，根据你的风格，到底有没有，对，所以有不同的钓鱼点供你去，它们有不同的深度，底部也有不同的东西。而且有一个发展历程、一个故事和一个结局，我不会剧透，但这是一个荒谬的故事，我觉得我并不是真的理解。
But then there eventually you get to an endless mode, and then kind of the, you can try to collect all the fish, you try to, anyways, various things. That sounds awesome. It's a pretty cool game but there's a story here which i think is fairly interesting so the developer of this vlam beer i'm probably saying that wrong also you might have heard of the game super crate box okay they maybe not they uh they made this game as well but they had i what was the name of it it was like
但随后你最终会进入无尽模式，然后有点像，你可以尝试收集所有的鱼，你尝试去，不管怎样，各种各样的事情。听起来太棒了。这是一款相当酷的游戏，但这里有一个故事，我觉得相当有趣，所以这个叫vlam beer的开发者，我大概念错了，也许你听说过《超级箱子方块》（Super Crate Box）这个游戏，好吧，也许没有，他们，他们也制作了这款游戏，但我有什么，它叫什么名字来着，就像是
radical fishing which was like a web game which was something i i get i haven't played it but something fairly similar and after they released that game that was like a web game, which was something, I haven't played it, but something fairly similar. And after they released that game, that was like 2011, I think, another company came out with something called Ninja Fishing, which was essentially what this Radical Fishing was, but just like for iOS devices. Oh, someone copied it. So someone copied them,
《激进钓鱼》（Radical Fishing），那是一个网页游戏，类似于，某种程度上我，我没玩过，但感觉相当类似。而在他们发布那个游戏之后，那大概是2011年吧，另一家公司推出了一个叫《忍者钓鱼》（Ninja Fishing）的游戏，它本质上就是这个《激进钓鱼》，只不过是针对iOS设备做的。哦，有人抄袭了它。所以有人抄袭了他们，
and they were already starting to make this ridiculous fishing. It was like a blank copy. People knew but like it was still i i what i gather like at least somewhat successful wow so what did they do like they just like went and spent more time like refining their game and it took them you know till now a couple years let it die down that thing to pass and then come out with this you know even better game and kind of like show them you know and supposedly it's doing really really well Wow anyways so I would encourage you to check it out three dollars that's right $2.99 it has has 3,000 ratings that's pretty high at least 3,000 people have bought it yeah yeah I don't know so yeah it's I don't think you can get the exact
而他们当时已经开始着手制作这款《荒谬钓鱼》了。这就像是一场抄袭。大家心知肚明，但据我所知，它至少还是取得了相当程度的成功，哇哦！那他们做了什么？就像是他们去花更多时间打磨自己的游戏，然后花了，你知道的，直到现在好几年时间，让那件事冷却、过去，然后推出了这款，你知道的，甚至更好的游戏，有点像是给他们好看，你知道的，而且据说明星产品现在卖得非常非常好。哇，不管怎样，所以我鼓励大家去看看，三美元，没错，2.99美元，它有3000个评分，这相当高了，至少有3000人买过它，是啊，我不知道，所以，是的，我觉着你拿不到他们实际的
number of downloads they've had they don't tell you but I think realistically like what is it like it's like at least one percent of people will rate yeah let's say like one in 25 percent of people rate to be to be conservative then multiply by 20 it's 60 000 downloads it's pretty good no that's not that good i think it's way better than that actually all right so i mean i think they've they've sold lots of it oh wow okay anyways but it's regardless of how many they've sold or not sold the destroyed, it's a ridiculous game and you should try it out. Yeah,
下载量数字，他们不会告诉你，但我觉得现实来看，是怎样的呢？就像是至少百分之一的人会去评分，对吧？让我们假设，保守一点说，百分之一点二五的人会评分，然后乘以20，那就是6万次下载，相当不错了，不，其实没那么好，我觉得实际上要好得多。好吧，所以我的意思是，他们已经卖出了很多很多份。哦，哇，好吧，不管怎样，但不管他们卖出了多少份或者没卖出多少份，这款游戏被毁了，它是一款荒谬的游戏，你应该去试试。是啊，
it sounds absolutely ridiculous. Hopefully, they'll make an Android version. Yeah. Anything 2D should be pretty straightforward. Should be straightforward. Yeah.
听起来绝对荒谬。希望他们会出一个安卓版本。是的。任何2D的东西都应该相当直接。应该很简单。是的。
I mean, that's always an interesting thing, right? Like, things which get made for one and not the other for various reasons and various people
我的意思是，那一直是一件有趣的事，对吧？比如，出于各种原因和不同的人，有些东西是为某个平台制作的而不是为另一个平台制作的
have opinions. See if they wrote it in TypeScript. You should mail them a letter, Jason. I know. You should get a petition should mail them a letter jason i know you should get a petition going buying our tools here you should you should get a petition going all right now it's time for the book of the show book of the show all right my book this show is a graphic novel which i always found find really funny like it's graphic like it's describes a lot of gore in the novel i'm
有各种看法。看看他们是不是用TypeScript写的。你应该给他们写封信，杰森。我知道。你应该发起一个请愿，应该给他们写封信，杰森，我知道，你应该发起一个请愿，在这里买我们的工具，你应当，你应当发起一个请愿。好吧，现在是本期节目图书推荐的时间了。本期节目图书，好吧，我的这本书是一部图像小说，我一直觉得这真的很有趣，就像它是图像小说，就像它在小说里描述了很多血腥暴力，我
fine i did it again i'm so sorry i'm fine being really immature and calling it comics like it doesn't bother me i don't feel like i'm less of a person anyways so this is a very long comic hundreds of pages but totally awesome and it's called dungeongeon. It's actually written by a couple of French a French author and illustrator but then Joanne Spahr and Louis Trondheim but then it was translated to English. It's pretty awesome basically the story is you know you've played so many video games where you have to go in the dungeon, slay the dragon, save the princess etc right or you've seen so many video games where you have to go in the dungeon, slay the dragon, save the princess, et cetera, right? Or you see in so many books or stories about it, right? This sort of takes that concept and turns it on its head. So the comic is about you are, the protagonist
好吧，我又来了，非常抱歉，我完全可以很幼稚地管它叫漫画，这并不困扰我，我不会觉得自己因此低人一等。总之，这是一部很长的漫画，有几百页，但绝对棒极了，它叫《地牢》（Dungeon）。它其实是由几个法国人，一个法国作家和一个插画家创作的，也就是Joann Sfar和Lewis Trondheim，但随后被翻译成了英文。它相当棒，基本上故事是这样的，你知道，你玩过那么多电子游戏，你得进入地牢，斩杀巨龙，拯救公主等等，对吧？或者你见过那么多电子游戏，你必须进入地牢，斩杀巨龙，拯救公主，诸如此类，对吧？或者你在许多书或相关故事中看到过，对吧？这本书采用了这个概念并将其颠覆了。所以这部漫画讲的是你，主角
is a dungeon master. And actually in the first volume, which is what I linked to, which you can buy through our Amazon web referral, which is pretty awesome, is you play as the son of a dungeon, or you follow the son of a dungeon master. And then the feature volumes, he sort of inherits the family business. The business is, you know, getting warriors to come into your dungeon, letting them slay some slimes and building up their confidence and letting them, you know, go back to the town, get some more weapons, come back. And then at some point, killing them and then taking all their armor and weapons and pawning them off. So that is the business of the dungeon.
是一个地牢地下城主。事实上，在第一卷中，也就是我链接到的那本，你可以通过我们的亚马逊网络推荐链接购买，这相当棒，你扮演的是一个地牢主人的儿子，或者你跟随地牢主人的儿子的视角。然后在接下来的几卷中，他有点像是继承了家族企业。这个生意是，你知道的，让勇士们进入你的地牢，让他们杀死一些史莱姆，建立他们的信心，让他们，你知道的，回到城镇，买更多的武器，再回来。然后在某个时刻，杀死他们，拿走他们所有的武器和装备，然后把它们当掉。所以这就是地牢的生意。
That's evil. Yeah, so if you ever played like Dungeon Keeper or any of these games, it's kind of like very paradoxical. And it's a pretty awesome awesome book highly recommend it. They have to go to their board meeting where the board of trustees looks in on the dungeon and sees the graphs and they talk about how they don't have hockey stick performance in their dungeon and what can we do
这太邪恶了。是的，所以如果你玩过《地下城守护者》（Dungeon Keeper）或任何此类游戏，这就非常具有悖论色彩。这是一本相当棒的书，强烈推荐。他们必须去参加董事会会议，信托董事会在会上视察地牢并查看图表，他们讨论为什么他们的地牢没有出现曲棍球杆式的业绩增长，以及我们能做什么
at one point they have a branding problem because the dungeon is too close to another dungeon so they kidnap a princess so that all these warriors start coming to their dungeon instead. And then the enemy dungeon kidnaps their princess back. So it's just pretty funny, pretty awesome, and I highly recommend it.
在某个时刻，他们遇到了品牌问题，因为这个地牢离另一个地牢太近了，所以他们绑架了一位公主，这样所有这些勇士就开始来到他们的地牢。然后敌方的地牢又把他们的公主绑架回去了。所以这非常有趣，非常棒，我强烈推荐它。
It's a great read. That does sound interesting. On the notion of lighthearted and less serious thing, my book is Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy. So this was written by Douglas Adams. I believe the order of this is that originally this was a radio show on the BBC. Right. And then he wrote this book. It makes, it's a very, if you've never heard of it before, read it before, a lot of pop culture geek references have their start in this book. Yeah. If there's a lot of jokes that you don't understand it's probably because you haven't read this book that's possible um but it's really it
这是一本极佳的读物。听起来确实很有趣。说到轻松且不那么严肃的事物，我的书是《银河系漫游指南》（Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy）。这本书是道格拉斯·亚当斯（Douglas Adams）写的。我相信它的顺序是，最初这是BBC的一个广播节目。没错。然后他写了这本书。它造就了，如果你以前从未听说过它、没读过它，许多流行文化极客梗都起源于这本书。是的。如果你有很多笑话看不懂，那可能是因为你还没读过这本书，这是有可能的，但它真的很
it's kind of like a comical take on science fiction with a lot of hilarity but it's a really good read there is a story there uh it has a lot of interesting tangents and things that don't always make sense but uh it's funny and it's it is really classic geek material yeah i mean they they interviewed you know there's been tons of interviews with douglas adams but one in particular that i read um he actually hitchhiked um throughout europe and he had a book called hitchhiker's guide to europe um and it was about sort of how to hitchhike through europe with no money and he went through europe completely penniless for months um and so that inspired him to write this hitchhiker's guide to
它有点像是对科幻小说的滑稽讽刺，充满了很多令人捧腹的笑料，但它确实是一本非常棒的读物。里面有一个故事，呃，它有很多有趣的题外话和并不总是讲得通的事情，但呃，它很有趣，而且确实是非常经典的极客素材。是的，我的意思是，他们采访过，你知道的，有过无数对道格拉斯·亚当斯的采访，但我读过其中特别的一篇，呃，他实际上在整个欧洲搭便车旅行，他有一本书叫《欧洲搭便车指南》，讲的是如何在没有钱的情况下搭便车游历欧洲，他身无分文地在欧洲游历了几个月，这激发了他写下这本《银河系漫游指南》，
the galaxy and so it's a phenomenal read so yeah yeah definitely um if you haven't read it before you should definitely check it out yeah totally and it's been it's been out for a while now 25 years at least yeah yeah so um yeah i mean it's it's a pretty reasonable price i think i i haven't bought it in a long time but uh i think i looked it up and it was it's okay that's right it, it's a pretty reasonable price, I think. I haven't bought it in a long time, but I think I looked it up and it was... It's okay. It's all right. It's well-priced and you can get... You probably can get a used copy if you want.
所以这是一部非凡的读物，所以，是的，绝对的，呃，如果你以前没读过，你绝对应该去看看，完全同意，而且它已经出版一段时间了，至少25年了，是啊，是啊，呃，所以，我的意思是，它的价格相当合理，我想，我已经很久没买过了，但呃，我想我查了一下，它是，好吧，没错，它的价格相当合理，我想。我已经很久没买过了，但我想我查了一下，它是……没关系。还好。它价格合理，而且你可以买到……如果你想的话，你可能还能买到二手书。
Yeah, $14. Oh, okay. Yeah, not $5. And there's... It's $5. It was... $14. Yeah, I was going to say, so it was supposed to be a trilogy, but it ended up being five
对，14美元。哦，好吧。是的，不是5美元。而且有……它是5美元。它是……14美元。对，我是想说，所以它本来应该是一个三部曲，但最终成了五
books. What is that called? Quintilogy? I guess. I guess. he has a funny name for i forget i've seen a quote by him about it but i can't recall what it is um but some classic uh characters from that book yeah so any book were not just this isn't too much of a spoiler because it's super early in the book but but any book which the earth gets destroyed on the first
本书。那叫什么来着？五部曲？我想是的。我想是的。他对这个有一个有趣的称呼，我忘了，我曾看过一句他关于这个的名言，但我记不清原话是什么了，呃，不过书里有一些经典的角色的确是的，所以任何一本书，这不仅仅是太多的剧透，因为这在书里超级靠前，但任何一本书，地球在第一
chapter has to be amazing right i mean mean, that sets the stage for awesome. As long as you make sure to bring your towel, you'll be okay. Yeah, definitely. All right. On to theoretical artificial intelligence. Okay. Maybe artificial intelligence theory. Yeah, definitely.
章就被毁灭了，它一定很棒，对吧？我的意思是，这为精彩的故事奠定了基础。只要你确保带上你的毛巾，你就会没事的。是的，绝对的。好了。接下来是理论人工智能。好吧。也许是人工智能理论。是的，绝对的。
So we're actually doing a two-parter. Two parts. So the first part is... And best of all, they're both free. What? This isn't like one of those Zynga games where we give you the first part and then we charge you $100. Wait, that's a brilliant idea.
所以我们实际上要做一个两部分的内容。两部分。所以第一部分是……最棒的是，它们都是免费的。什么？这不像那些Zynga游戏，我们给你第一部分，然后向你收取100美元。等等，这是个绝妙的主意。
No, because then the first part would have to be really good, and then the second part wouldn't be as good, and then people would be mad and want their money back. We're setting up microtransactions. We're just going to go on tangents until you pay us a dollar. Please insert coin here. Yeah. To continue, that would be 25 cents further, please.
不，因为那样的话第一部分就必须非常好，然后第二部分就没那么好，接着人们就会生气并要求退款。我们在设置微交易。我们只是要不断扯淡，直到你付给我们一美元。请在此投币。是的。要继续，请再付25美分。
Yeah. Oh, man. So you have on here the Turk. No, first we're going to talk about, we will not cover everything in AI because we don't have enough time. Yeah, definitely. So this, I liken this to, we'll do a tour of artificial intelligence.
天哪。哦，伙计。所以你这里提到了“土耳其人”。不，首先我们要讨论的是，我们不会涵盖人工智能的方方面面，因为我们没有足够的时间。是的，绝对的。所以这个，我把它比作，我们将进行一次人工智能之旅。
Yeah. Jason and I will be your tour guides. Definitely, we'll hold hands, hold your hands. What? Stop. We'll hold your hands and walk you through the world of AI. So we're going to go over some highlights. This is by no means comprehensive,
是的。我和杰森将是你们的导游。当然，我们会手拉手，拉着你们的手。什么？住手。我们会拉着你们的手，带你们走过AI的世界。所以我们要讲一些亮点。这绝不是全面的，
and we may try to shorten some things, and hopefully that's not too bad. If there's anything we miss and you really want to hear about, feel free to email us. Next episode, we'll read some listener feedback. Yeah. And you guys have been doing that, and so keep doing that.
而且我们可能会试图缩短一些内容，希望不会太糟糕。如果我们有什么遗漏而你真的很想听，欢迎给我们发电子邮件。下一期节目，我们会读一些听众反馈。是的。你们一直在这么做，所以请继续保持。
And if you have something you want to hear, you know, please go ahead and write us. Let us know. We can cover something in more detail. I don't know that we could cover something in less detail because we'll have already covered it but we'll do our best so my favorite AI thing when I think about AI
如果你有什么想听的内容，你知道的，请尽管给我们写信。让我们知道。我们可以更详细地探讨某些内容。我不知道我们能否以更不详细的方式探讨某些内容，因为我们已经讲过了，但我们会尽力而为。所以当我想到AI时，我最喜欢的AI东西
this is kind of bad, I don't know, I think about the Turk so if you don't know what the Turk is this was in the 18th century I guess it started around 1770 was kind of the exact time and this was an build as a mechanical automata chess master right so this was a robot you could go visit who sat in front of a chess table and would play chess very well keep in mind 17 1770 people were amazed they went on tour
这有点糟糕，我不知道，我想到了“土耳其棋手”（The Turk）。如果你不知道“土耳其棋手”是什么，这是在18世纪，我猜它始于1770年前后，大概是这个确切时间，这是一个被称为机械自动机国际象棋大师的装置，对吧？所以这是一个你可以去参观的机器人，它坐在国际象棋桌前，棋艺非常高超。请记住，在1770年，人们惊叹不已，它进行了巡回展出
for nearly a hundred years um and people would pay to come see it it would saw it was it was just like a you know what in the world like this machine people were amazed to see this machine that could could beat you could play i remember um going to this is really weird but going to north carolina as like uh probably like a third or fourth grader with my family and going somewhere where they had like various arcade machines and they had a chicken that played tic-tac-toe What so you it was it this is really bad Like I don't people people should not have done this but it lived inside like one of those crane machines You know like the cranes right now, but no crane but no crane day but like in like a glass box and
将近一百年，呃，人们花钱来看它，它，这就像是一个，你知道的，这到底是怎么回事，一台机器，人们惊叹于看到这台机器能够击败你，能够下棋。我记得，呃，去过，这真的很奇怪，但作为，大概三四年级的学生和我的家人一起去北卡罗来纳州，去某个地方，那里有各种街机，他们有一只打井字棋的鸡。什么？所以你，它，这真的很糟糕，就像，人们不应该这样做，但它住在一个像抓娃娃机那样的东西里面，你知道，就像现在的抓娃娃机，但没有抓子，但没有抓子，而是像在一个玻璃箱里，
You would put a quarter in and the chicken would go first So I assume what happened they drop a little feed into this box and the chicken would go over and pack and it was labeled like you know input box or something and and the chicken would pack and then you know the screen would show what what uh position it picked and then you would you would go next and then the chicken would go over and pack some more food and then you would you would just back and forth and the chicken was unbeatable nobody could beat the chicken and and so i guess like maybe it's like early childhood memory of not being able to beat a chicken like being embarrassed that i couldn't beat a chicken at tic-tac-toe like like shaped my life um and so the turk was similar this was this machine and
你会投进去一枚硬币，然后这只鸡会先走，所以我猜发生的事情是，它们在这个箱子里掉落了一点饲料，然后这只鸡就会过去啄，上面贴着类似“输入框”之类的标签，然后鸡啄了一下，接着，你知道的，屏幕会显示它选择了什么位置，然后轮到你走，接着鸡会过去再啄一些食物，然后你就会，就这么你来我往，而且这只鸡是不可战胜的，没人能打败这只鸡，所以我想，也许这是我童年时无法打败一只鸡的记忆，因为无法在井字棋中击败一只鸡而感到尴尬，塑造了我的一生，所以“土耳其棋手”也很类似，这是一个机器，并且
you know i think there's a lot of drawings of you know like kind of the chest was open you could see all these gears you know these gears wearing and spinning and figuring out how to play chess. And for 100 years, people were amazed at this. And then it was finally destroyed in a fire. And they wrote about the secret of the Turk was that there were chess masters inside of him cleverly hiding themselves
你知道，我认为有很多关于，你知道的，国际象棋棋盘是打开的图纸，你可以看到所有的齿轮，你知道这些齿轮在转动、旋转，并计算着如何下棋。在长达100年的时间里，人们对此惊叹不已。然后它最终在一场大火中被毁了。人们写文章披露“土耳其棋手”的秘密是，里面巧妙地藏着象棋大师，
and manipulating the arms of the robot to play chess but you know i think and we can go through like history of like all these like things people thinking about and talking about ai but just like the kind of amazement that the average person has with some machine something that's not human but smarter than them yeah yeah definitely that's pretty awesome that's where amazon mechanical turd came from. Yeah, so, yeah, yeah. Nice, clever name. Pretty awesome. So, yeah, I mean, so one of the hallmarks of early AI was Alan Turing's Turing test. And it basically, in a nutshell, says that if a human can't tell whether they're interacting with a computer or another human, then said computer has passed the Turing test.
操纵着机器人的手臂来下棋。但你知道，我认为，我们可以回顾历史，了解人们对AI的所有这些思考和讨论，只是普通人对某种机器、对某种非人类但比他们更聪明的东西所感到的那种惊叹，是的，是的，绝对的，这太棒了，“亚马逊土耳其机器人”（Amazon Mechanical Turk）就是由此而来的。所以，是的，不错，聪明的名字。太棒了。所以，是的，我的标志之一，早期AI的一个标志就是阿兰·图灵的图灵测试。简而言之，它基本上是说，如果人类无法分辨他们是在与计算机交互还是与另一个人交互，那么该计算机就通过了图灵测试。
And so that's been something that sort of AI people have constantly gone back to. Yeah, it kind of goes to what I'm saying, right? Like that people want to know something smarter than themselves. So if you could make, like, how do you tell when a computer is intelligent? If you can't tell the difference between it and a human, it's at least as intelligent as a human. Yeah, yeah, and we'll definitely cover that because there's a lot of interesting areas that can go there. Also, we talked about last episode, I believe, our book was Foundation Series by Isaac Asimov.
所以这一直是AI界人士不断回溯的东西。是的，这有点符合我刚才说的，对吧？人们想要认识比自己更聪明的东西。所以如果你能制造出，怎么判断一台计算机是否具备智能？如果你无法区分它和一个人类，那么它至少和人类一样聪明。是的，是的，我们绝对会讲到这一点，因为那里有很多有趣的领域。此外，我们上一期节目好像聊过我们的书，也就是艾萨克·阿西莫夫的《基地》系列。
And I think that was my book. And Isaac Asimov also has a very popular kind of thing related to artificial intelligence and robotics in particular where he had the three laws of robotics which are a robot may not injure a human being or through inaction allow a human being to come to harm number two a robot must obey orders given to it by human beings except where such orders conflict with the first law and three a robot must protect its own existence as long as such protection does not conflict with the first or second laws so anyways read all that to say that i think it's interesting that people were fascinated and are still fascinated by these laws to think that you could get to the point where it would even matter that you had these laws like that if something was capable of being worrying about whether or not it obeyed by the laws you would you had kind of arrived right and to think
我想那是我的书。艾萨克·阿西莫夫还有一个非常受欢迎的、与人工智能特别是机器人学相关的概念，那就是他提出了机器人三定律：第一定律，机器人不得伤害人类，或者坐视人类受到伤害；第二定律，机器人必须服从人类给予它的命令，除了这些命令与第一定律相冲突的情况；第三定律，机器人必须保护其自身的生存，只要这种保护不与第一 or 第二定律相冲突。总之，读完全文就是想说，我觉得很有趣的是，人们曾经并且现在仍然对这些定律着迷，认为你会达到这样一种地步：甚至拥有这些定律都变得重要起来，就好像如果某种东西有能力去担心它是否遵守了法律，你就已经算是一种抵达了，对吧？而且去思考
about you know the laws of robotics dealing with safety and being so integrated with safety shows sort of the inherent fear of AI, right? Even today, people are worried that, you know, some AI will go horribly wrong or AI will take over the world. We don't need people. Yeah, it's a classic Terminator thing, right? Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
你知道的，机器人三定律处理的是安全问题，并且与安全如此紧密地结合在一起，这表明了对AI的一种固有恐惧，对吧？即使在今天，人们也担心，你知道的，某些AI会严重出错，或者AI会接管世界。我们不需要人类。是的，这是一个经典的终结者设定，对吧？是的，完全正确。是的。
Yeah. So people are like fascinated and fearful of you know going back to the turk like that this thing can be smarter than them and that they won't have a good way to stop it right right so uh in the early 50s there's a lot of pioneering work there's the first neural network which we'll cover in more detail uh definitely in the second episode but suffice it to say that there's an artificial neural network which is sort of a mathematical approximation of sort of the electrical patterns that go on in a human brain and the plasticity of that in other words how your brain sort of transforms to to capture information and store it there. And we'll cover that in more detail. There's also Arthur Samuel's famous checkers AI,
所以人们既着迷又恐惧，就像回到“土耳其棋手”一样，担心这东西会比他们更聪明，而且他们没有好办法阻止它，对吧？所以，在50年代初，有很多开创性的工作，有第一个神经网络，我们将在第二集中更详细地探讨它，绝对会讲，但简而言之，存在人工神经网络，它算是人类大脑中发生的电信号模式以及大脑可塑性的一种数学近似，换句话说，你的大脑如何进行转化以捕获信息并将其存储在那里。我们将更详细地探讨这一点。还有亚瑟·塞缪尔（Arthur Samuel）著名的西洋跳棋AI，
where some concepts like mini Macs and planning and things like that were introduced. And I think it's interesting, like the relationship of even today games and artificial intelligence, because I think it's a way for like defining a set of rule, almost like the Turing test, right? Like you're defining a world that has a set of rules, the game, and then you're allowing, you can pit yourself against the opponent, the computer. They're like, you can put somebody on the other end.
其中引入了诸如极小化极大算法（mini-max）、规划等概念。而且我觉得很有趣，比如即使在今天，游戏与人工智能的关系也是如此，因为我认为这是一种定义规则集的方法，几乎就像图灵测试一样，对吧？就像你定义了一个拥有规则集的世界，即游戏，然后你允许自己与对手（计算机）对弈。你可以把某个人放在另一端。
And as long as if you're both obeying by the same set of rules, you've essentially created a level playing field. Yeah, yeah, definitely. So playing a computer in checkers, like if it can beat you in checkers, you know, in some ways like it's bested you at checkers, right? Right, like in the domain of checkers, it's easy to pass the Turing test, right?
只要你们都遵守同一套规则，你本质上就创造了一个公平的竞技场。是的，是的，绝对的。所以跟电脑玩西洋跳棋，如果它能在西洋跳棋中击败你，在某种程度上就像它在西洋跳棋中胜过了你，对吧？没错，就像在西洋跳棋这个领域里，通过图灵测试很容易，对吧？
It's much harder to pass the Turing test when, you know, locomotion, speech, all of these other things are involved, right? I mean, once you've done that, then you've made a- Although interestingly, you and I went to a talk by a person who does board game design and i thought he had an interesting point where he was saying that writing a game for the computer it's very sometimes it's very easy to write an ai but playing an ai is very different from playing a human oh that's true that you can make so passing the turn test of checkers is like you can win at checkers but people don't
当涉及到运动、演讲以及所有这些其他事情时，要通过图灵测试就难得多，对吧？我的意思是，一旦你做到了这一点，你就创造了一个——尽管有趣的是，你和我去听过一个桌游设计师的讲座，我觉得他有一个有趣的观点，他说为电脑编写游戏，有时编写AI非常容易，但与AI对弈和与人类对弈非常不同。哦，那是真的。你可以做到，所以通过西洋跳棋的图灵测试就像是你在西洋跳棋中获胜，但人们并没有
get the feeling that they're playing a human. You're playing distinctly different and maybe in a way that a human wouldn't normally play. Like he mentioned over-aggressiveness. Often human opponents will try to play well without being mean, but the computer is just going to do whatever is best in its odds. Another thing too is, say take checkers for example so you learn to play checkers from a human learns to play checkers from either somebody or a book that somebody has written so there's sort of this what's called the quote-unquote eternal
那种在和人类对弈的感觉。你的对弈方式明显不同，也许这种方式人类通常不会采用。比如他提到过分激进。人类对手通常会试图把棋下好而不显得刻薄，但电脑只会做概率上最好的事情。另一件事是，比如说拿西洋跳棋举例，人类向某个人或者某本别人写过的书学习怎么玩西洋跳棋，所以这就有了所谓的引用的
conversation um there's an eternal conversation on checkers so the first people who invented checkers said some things about it and how it captures some part of the world of world dynamics. That's probably what inspired them to make checkers. Probably war or something like that. Then there's people who sort of took that, expounded on it, expounded on it. Some people wrote books on strategies. And so your understanding of checkers is actually derived from the people who taught it to you and then subsequently everybody else in that stream, right? Whereas a computer is just going to learn checkers as a mathematical function, right? So it might be exploring checkers in a completely different
永恒对话，呃，关于西洋跳棋有一场永恒的对话。所以最早发明西洋跳棋的人对它说了一些话，以及它是如何捕捉世界动态的某一部分的。这可能就是启发他们制作西洋跳棋的原因。可能是战争或类似的东西。然后有人承袭了这一点，对其进行了阐述、再阐述。有些人写了关于策略的书。所以你对西洋跳棋的理解实际上来自于教你的人，以及随后那个流派里的所有人，对吧？而电脑只是把西洋跳棋当作一个数学函数来学习，对吧？所以它探索西洋跳棋的轨迹可能和你完全不同。
vector than you are. Yeah. So almost like if somebody makes an analogy to you about how to determine what to do, then you're likely to make different decisions in the computer, which doesn't understand how to equate playing checkers to moving in a cornfield. Yeah, exactly. I don't know if that's making sense. That's why game AI is so hard. People think, oh, game AI, you know, I'll do all this planning and stuff like that. And they think all these sophisticated methods and things that the Mars Rover would use, right?
所以这几乎就像如果有人向你做一个类比，教你如何决定该怎么做，那么你很可能会做出与电脑不同的决定，因为电脑并不懂得如何把下西洋跳棋等同于在玉米地里移动。是的，完全正确。我不知道这讲得通不讲得通。这就是为什么游戏AI如此困难的原因。人们认为，哦，游戏AI，你知道的，我会做所有这些规划之类的事情，他们想到了火星车会使用的所有这些复杂方法，对吧？
But it doesn't really work. I mean, think about it, like, even just in Mario, if the Goombas bounced every now and then, that'd probably be harder to jump on them, right? But that doesn't make the game more fun, right? Part of what makes Mario fun is the predictability. You hit the turtle shell, it knocks eight Goombas in a row, you get a one-up, you know, it makes your brain happy, right?
但它实际上并不起作用。我的意思是，想想看，即使在《马里奥》中，如果板栗仔（Goomba）时不时地弹跳一下，那跳上去可能会更难，对吧？但这并不会让游戏更好玩，对吧？马里奥好玩的部分原因在于可预测性。你踢飞乌龟壳，它连续撞倒八只板栗仔，你得到一条命，你知道的，这会让你的大脑感到快乐，对吧？
Serotonin's released. So making a computer that can sort of facilitate a fun experience is actually really hard a lot harder than making as you mentioned the perfect player right so leading into the 1950s in the quote-unquote golden age of artificial intelligence yeah so so at this point everyone thought oh we have it we figured out neural networks and we know how the brain you know works and how electricity causes you to store information so that's it we figured out neural networks and we know how the brain you know works and how electricity causes you to store information so that's it we got it figured out we're going to have human level intelligence and they thought that for about 15 years uh 20 years or so and
血清素释放了。所以制造一个能够促进有趣体验的电脑实际上非常困难，比你刚才提到的制造完美玩家要难得多。所以这就引向了20世纪50年代，也就是所谓的“人工智能黄金时代”。是的，所以在这一点上，每个人都认为，哦，我们成功了，我们弄懂了神经网络，我们知道了大脑是如何运作的，以及电流是如何导致你存储信息的，所以就是这样，我们搞懂了神经网络，我们知道了大脑是如何运作的，以及电流是如何导致你存储信息的，所以就是这样，我们弄明白了，我们将拥有人类水平的智能。他们这样认为大约有15年，20年左右，然后
realize it's not true and we'll get into why that is but um but yeah so so after the golden age which is around mid 70s um we have what's called the AI winter. And this is where people started to lose faith in AI. And the goals that AI set were so lofty that even if AI had made tremendous progress, which it didn't, it still would have gone through this period of remission, right? But it went through a terrible winter where basically people thought AI was kind of dead there's not really a point to it then in the 90s you have this sort of Renaissance of AI a lot of people attribute the Renaissance of AI to you know better faster computers Moore's Law things like that and also just more sophisticated methods and just a lot of infrastructure, both on the research and on the computation side.
意识到这不是真的，我们将探讨为什么会这样。但是，是的，所以在黄金时代之后，大约是在70年代中期，我们迎来了所谓的“AI寒冬”。这就是人们开始对AI失去信心的时候。AI设定的目标是如此崇高，以至于即使AI取得了巨大的进展——实际上它并没有——它仍然会经历这样一个衰退期，对吧？但它经历了一个可怕的寒冬，基本上人们认为AI已经死了，没有什么意义了。然后在90年代，你迎来了AI的复兴。许多人将AI的复兴归功于你知道的，更好、更快的计算机、摩尔定律之类的事情，还有更复杂的方法，以及在研究和计算两端的大量基础设施。
In 1996 was when Deep Blue supercomputer and program combo beat Garry Kasparov in chess. And I always find this story interesting because, first of all, I didn't even realize it was that recent. Well, relatively recent, I guess. Yeah, totally. And it's kind of like if you look at their checkers world-class checkers in 51 and it took 45 years to play something that's played on the same board you play chess and checkers on the same or you can play on the same board yeah i think it's even the same size yeah
1996年，深蓝（Deep Blue）超级计算机和程序组合击败了加里·卡斯帕罗夫（Garry Kasparov）。我总是觉得这个故事很有趣，首先，我甚至没意识到那是这么近的事。嗯，相对近期吧，我猜。是的，完全是。而且就像如果你看看他们1951年世界级的西洋跳棋，花了45年时间才开发出能在你下棋的棋盘上玩的程序，国际象棋和西洋跳棋在同一个，或者你可以在同一个棋盘上下，是的，我想它们甚至是一样大的，是的，
same size same board right and just different pieces different rules or whatever and like look how drastically different and i mean obviously chess you can even tell simply it's much more complex than checkers. But, like, you know, it took all this time to kind of get there. That's interesting to me. It's also interesting, like, this huge controversy over, like, were people helping it? Like, you know, was it a ploy by IBM to increase their stock price? Like, nobody's ever fully convinced that they i mean today i think people are fairly settled that it's at least my understanding it's pretty hard like chess you can sometimes beat a
相同的大小，相同的棋盘，对吧？只是棋子不同，规则不同，诸如此类。你看它们的差距有多大，显然国际象棋，你可以简单地看出，它比西洋跳棋复杂得多。但是，你知道，花了这么长时间才走到这一步。这对我来说很有趣。也有趣的是，比如，这场巨大的争论，关于，是不是有人在帮它？就像，你知道，这是IBM为了提高股价而耍的花招吗？从来没有人完全确信，我的意思是，今天我认为人们基本达成共识，至少据我所知，很难，就像国际象棋，你有时可以击败
chess computer like the world-class ones but yeah now it's at the point where the best chess computers beat the best players and it's it's sort of a given right that's going to remain forever yeah so now but back then like in for you know in the intermeeting years there was a time when it wasn't quite clear and even then right like you would think oh that was the first time that a computer had beat a reigning world chess master and so like okay like that's it right like but yeah maybe there's all these caveats and you know special cases and one of the things i remember that was up for contention was they actually put all of kasparov's games that he's ever played into deep blue's um you know repository so deep blue knew kind of kasparov strategies specifically and so the argument was oh if we took someone who wasn't kasparov you know like would you have to train for each person
国际象棋电脑，比如世界级的那些，但是，是的，现在已经到了最强的国际象棋电脑能击败最强的选手的地步，这可以说是一个既定事实了，对吧？那将永远持续下去。是的，所以现在，但在那时，在随后的几年里，曾有一段时间情况并不明朗，即便如此，对吧？你会想，哦，那是计算机第一次击败现任世界国际象棋大师，所以就像，好吧，就是这样，对吧？但也许这其中有很多附加条件和特例，我记得有争议的一点是，他们实际上把卡斯帕罗夫下过的所有比赛都输入了深蓝的，呃，你知道的数据库里，所以深蓝专门了解卡斯帕罗夫的策略，所以当时的争论是，如果我们找一个不是卡斯帕罗夫的人，你知道的，你会不会必须针对每个人进行训练，
or is the system general? At the time, I think some of those were valid. I think that if you had another famous chess player play Deep Blue, you would have to train on that person for a while as well. But now they've gotten to the point where they'll beat anybody.
还是这个系统是通用的？在当时，我认为其中一些观点是成立的。我认为如果你让另一个著名的国际象棋选手与深蓝对弈，你也必须针对那个人训练一段时间。但现在它们已经发展到可以击败任何人的地步了。
What is artificial intelligence? Alright, here we're getting some of the meat of the podcast. Alright, let's let me get my soapbox out for me to stand up okay so i'll take a seat so first let's talk about intelligence right because this by itself is pretty loaded right so um when you talk about intelligence you're talking almost certainly about human or animal intelligence right and so lack or lack of it yeah if you're watching real world then you know so so a lot so there's there's two main sources of intelligence
什么是人工智能？好吧，在这里我们切入播客的核心内容了。好吧，让我把我的肥皂箱拿出来，让我站上去。好吧，那我先坐下。首先，我们来谈谈智能，对吧？因为这个概念本身就很重磅。所以，当你谈论智能时，你几乎可以肯定是在谈论人类或动物的智能，对吧？以及有或没有它，对吧？如果你在看现实世界，那么你知道的，所以，所以很多，所以有两个主要的智能来源：
one is neural plasticity so this is you know if I tell you hey my phone number is five four five five five five, whatever. That's not really your number. No, I'm getting phone calls already. Then a week later, you know, I ask you what my phone number is and you recite it to me, right? There's intelligence and just memorization. And at a higher level, if you learn the layout of your house and then the next week you unlock the front door and go straight to the living room because you know where it is, right? So there's that kind of intelligence that's learned after you're born. There's also a tremendous amount of innate intelligence. And so this is actually intelligence that is encoded in your DNA.
一个是神经可塑性，也就是，如果我告诉你，嘿，我的电话号码是545-555，随便什么。那其实不是你的号码。不，我已经接到电话了。然后一周后，你知道的，我问你我的电话号码是什么，你把它背诵给我听，对吧？这里有智能，也有单纯的死记硬背。而在更高的层面上，如果你了解你房子的布局，然后第二周你用钥匙打开前门，径直走到起居室，因为你知道它在哪里，对吧？所以这种智能是在你出生后学习获得的。还有数量庞大的先天智能。所以这其实是编码在你DNA中的智能。
So your brain is actually constructed with a certain set of structures. You know structures for language, structures for vision, and a lot of these structures have incredible complexity and what I would call intelligence in them. And so you know things like vision, language understanding, these things are innate. They're not learned. It's not like you know you might be blind, I think babies are blind when they're born, but that's not a mental thing. That's just a physiological aspect. But you actually have a tremendous amount of innate knowledge. Just to put it in perspective, giraffes and other quadrupeds, when they're born, they can see, they can actually run immediately on birth.
所以你的大脑实际上是用一组特定的结构构建的。你知道的，用于语言的结构、用于视觉的结构，其中许多结构具有令人难以置信的复杂性，以及我称之为其中的智能。所以，你知道，像视觉、语言理解这些东西都是天生的。它们不是后天学习的。这不像是，你知道的，你可能会失明，我想婴儿刚出生时是盲的，但这并不是心理层面的。那只是生理上的一个方面。但你实际上拥有海量的先天知识。为了有个直观的概念，长颈鹿和其他四足动物在出生时就能看见东西，实际上在出生时就能立即奔跑。
In fact, giraffes specifically, they fall, I think, three or four feet out of the womb and immediately get up and run. So that's intelligence. I don't think babies are actually born blind, though. It's something slightly different, but it's okay. Continue on. Oh, is it? Well, yeah, that was a jump. But the point is, I know for a fact that babies are not born without the ability to see on a cognitive level, right? So, okay, so that's intelligence. And intelligence is sort of passed on through the generations.
事实上，长颈鹿具体来说，它们从子宫里掉下来，我想有三四英尺高，然后立刻站起来奔跑。所以这就是智能。不过我不认为婴儿出生时真的是盲的。那是稍微有点不同的情况，但没关系。继续吧。哦，是吗？好吧，是的，刚才那是个跳跃。但重点是，我很确定婴儿出生时并不是在认知层面上没有看见东西的能力，对吧？所以，好吧，这就是智能。而智能是通过一代代传承下来的。
It's encoded in our DNA, and our DNA is constantly undergoing mutations and things like that to add more intelligence and to make it more amenable, right? So this is a very slow process. It's not like your child is going to be born knowing geometry or something like that. It doesn't really work that way. But the fact is that people born now, or animals, let's say, born now are much more intelligent than protosomes born millions of years ago, right? So now let's talk about artificial intelligence. So we want to emulate human intelligence. Like we want computers, as we mentioned in the Turing test, to have conversations with us, to see, to recognize objects, to
它被编码在我们的DNA中，而我们的DNA不断经历突变之类的事情，以增加更多的智能并使其更具适应性，对吧？所以这是一个非常缓慢的过程。这并不是说你的孩子出生就会几何或者类似的东西。事情不是那样运作的。但事实是，现在出生的人，或者动物，比如说，现在出生的要比几百万年前的原生动物聪明得多，对吧？所以现在我们来谈谈人工智能。所以我们想要模拟人类智能。就像我们想要的计算机，正如我们在图灵测试中提到的那样，能够与我们对话，能够看见东西，能够识别物体，能够
do all these things. But we don't have an earth simulator, right? And even if we did have a complete earth simulator that could really, really quickly simulate the entire process on earth and evolution and all these different speciation and all these things, genetic drift, et cetera, it wouldn't probably come out the same, right? Unless we had an exact copy of Earth as a seed, we would come up with some other intelligent hypothetical species, right? So we can't go back and recreate human intelligence. Like, it's just not possible. So artificial intelligence is our way
做所有这些事情。但我们没有地球模拟器，对吧？即使我们有一个完整的地球模拟器，能够非常非常快地模拟地球上的整个过程、演化以及所有这些不同的物种形成和所有这些事情、遗传漂变等等，它可能也不会得出相同的结​​果，对吧？除非我们有地球的精确复制品作为种子，否则我们会提出一些其他聪明的假设物种，对吧？所以我们不能回到过去并重现人类智能。就像，这根本不可能。所以人工智能是我们的方式
of saying knowing we can't do that how can we still make something that passes this Turing test how can we make computers that sort of you know live in our world don't really know our history but are still able to relate to you know to the way that we the way that we behave and interact so that's that's kind of my that's my that's my jason gauti's soapbox opinion of uh intelligence and ai so i always find it interesting the discussion about artificial intelligence like you know these kinds of things about there seems to be different camps like some people who deeply believe in needing to understand how the brain works other people saying it doesn't matter we don't we can do something else and still be fine you know or like you alluded to like maybe
说既然知道我们做不到这一点，我们怎样才能仍然制造出能够通过这个图灵测试的东西，我们怎样才能制造出那种生活在我们的世界里、并不真正了解我们的历史、但仍然能够与我们联系起来的计算机呢？我们做事的方式，我们的行为和互动方式，所以这有点像我的、那是我的、那是我的杰森·高蒂（Jason Gauti）关于人工智能的肥皂盒观点；所以我总是觉得关于人工智能的讨论很有趣，比如你知道这些关于似乎有不同阵营的事情，有些人深信需要了解大脑的工作原理，另一些人则说没关系，我们不需要这样做，我们可以做其他事情而且仍然很好，你知道，或者就像你暗示的那样，也许
it's important to figure out what you think happened and how we got here other people not not so much we don't need to do that but people can still make progress and you know create useful things regardless of which one of these camps they kind of fall into or which which path they're considering. Yeah, definitely. Yeah. I mean, I think you need you definitely need to do both. So there are some concessions you have to make. I mean, the reality is human intelligence is almost certainly not perfect.
弄清楚你认为发生了什么以及我们是如何走到这一步的是很重要的，其他人则不然，我们不需要这样做，但无论他们属于哪一个阵营，人们仍然可以取得进步并创造有用的东西他们正在考虑哪条路径。是的，绝对的。是的，我的意思是，我认为你需要你绝对需要兼顾这两者。所以你必须做出一些让步。我的意思是，现实是人类的智能几乎肯定不是完美的。
Right. I mean, there's almost certainly speak for yourself. Hey, those certainly unless we all had Patrick's brain, there's almost certainly a better brain out there, right? Like some other thing. And of course, there are things that computers are much better at than we are, like arithmetic. We'll never match a computer's ability to do that. But on the other hand, we want computers to pass that Turing test, which is fundamentally a human evaluation. It's a human domain that you want computers to succeed in. So you have to sort of do this balance between,
对。我的意思是，几乎肯定——说你自己吧。嘿，毫无疑问——除非我们都有帕特里克的脑子，否则外面几乎肯定有一个更好的大脑，对吧？就像其他东西一样。当然，计算机在很多方面都比我们擅长，比如算术。我们永远无法匹敌计算机在这方面的能力。但另一方面，我们希望计算机通过图灵测试，这从根本上说是一个人类的评估。这是您希望计算机取得成功的人类领域。所以你必须在以下方面做出平衡：
you know, studying the brain and so, you know, sort of like, I guess, hacking the brain, quote unquote. Because we mentioned in image processing, where you encode the blue, I believe it was blue, right? Yeah, you encode the blue channel more lossy than you encode the blue, I believe it was blue, right? Yeah, you encode the blue channel more lossy than you encode the red channel because humans are, you know, less adept to blue. So that's sort of an example of someone coming at it from the biological side, right? But there's plenty of things on the mathematical side too
你知道，研究大脑，所以，你知道，有点像，我猜，黑客大脑，引号引起来。因为我们在图像处理中提到过，你对蓝色进行编码，我相信是蓝色，对吧？是的，你对蓝色通道的编码比对蓝色通道的编码更有损，我相信是蓝色，对吧？是的，你对蓝色通道的编码比对红色通道更有损，因为人类对蓝色不太适应，你知道的。所以这有点像从生物学角度切入的例子，对吧？但数学方面也有很多东西
which can make a big difference. Yeah, and then in my opinion too, I think there's been somewhat of a shift from like artificial intelligence is all about passing the turing test to like you know and people point out things like search engines as this right like they can do a lot of very useful things right which whether or not that's intelligence it's unknown but it's definitely a very useful thing that people that isn't an outcome of passing the Turing test. Right. Getting an AI sufficient to pass the Turing test
这可以产生很大的不同。是的，在我看来，人工智能已经从完全关于通过图灵测试转变为类似的东西，人们指出了搜索引擎之类的事情就是这样的例子——它们可以做很多非常有趣的事情，不管这是否是智能，这还是未知的，但这绝对是一件非常有用的事情，人们并不是通过图灵测试的结果。对。获得足以通过图灵测试的人工智能
doesn't solve the search engine problem. Exactly. So we get things which, you know, and maybe that's machine learning, maybe it's artificial, I mean, whatever you want to call it. But, you know, kind of the advancements of computer, the future was always making a computer which was equivalent of a human.
并不能解决搜索引擎的问题。准确地说。所以我们得到了这样的东西，你知道，也许那是机器学习，也许它是人工的，我的意思是，无论你想怎么称呼它。但是，你知道，计算机的发展，未来永远是制造一台相当于人类的计算机。
Yet we kind of ended up developing this other side branch where it was like, oh, making computers do even things that are more useful than what a human would be kind of ended up developing this other side branch where it was like oh making computers do even things that are more useful than what a human would be able to do yeah definitely yeah it's a really good point so uh yeah along these lines uh this was a hot topic a long time ago before either of us were born but it's still really important and that's common sense knowledge so when you hear this term sort of common sense you think of things like if I was to ask a child what's taller a skyscraper or your house or you know things like that they would just they have this a ton of common sense reasoning right and that's because human
然而，我们最终开发了另一个分支，就像，哦，让计算机做甚至比人类更有用的事情，最终开发了另一个分支，就像，哦，让计算机做甚至比人类更有用的事情能够做到这一点，是的，绝对是，这是一个非常好的点子，所以，沿着这些思路，这在很久以前、在我们俩出生之前是一个热门话题，但它仍然非常重要，那就是常识知识——所以当你听到这个词时，比如常识，你会想到这样的事情：如果我问一个孩子，摩天大楼和你的房子哪个更高，或者诸如此类的事情，他们就会拥有这种大量的常识推理能力，对吧，这是因为人类
beings absorb an incredible amount of data I mean in the image processing episode last episode, we talked about how much data is in video, right? Uncompressed video. And it was enormous. It was like a dictionary every 10th of a second or something like that. You can fit the entire dictionary. So that's just from your eye, right? You have actually a lot of sensation in your ears, your nose, touch, especially your fingertips. And all of those data sources are extremely rich, and there's a ton of data, way more data than any computer can come close to processing even today. So the fact that humans are able to digest and process so much information is another
人类吸收了令人难以置信的数据量——我的意思是，在上一集的图像处理那一集里，我们讨论了视频中包含多少数据，对吧？未压缩的视频。而且规模极其庞大。每十分之一秒就有一个字典什么的。你可以塞进整本字典。所以这只是来自你的眼睛，对吧？实际上，你的耳朵、鼻子、触觉，尤其是指尖，都有很多感觉。所有这些数据源都极其丰富，而且有大量数据，远超当今任何计算机所能处理的数据量。因此，人类能够消化和处理如此大量的信息，是人工智能的另一个方面
aspect of AI that we're starting to make progress on. Especially now, there's that open crawl, which has the entire internet, 50 terabytes of the internet in it or something. So with things like search engines, databases, and things like that, we're able to create a small sample of the knowledge that we experience every day. And so we're starting to make progress there. Yeah, I don't know. It's fascinating having a child and watch them, like, what they pick up and learn
我们开始取得进展的方面。尤其是现在，有一个“开放抓取”（Open Crawl），里面包含了整个互联网，互联网上有 50 太字节的内容什么的。因此，通过搜索引擎、数据库之类的事物，我们能够创建我们每天经历的知识的一小部分样本。所以我们开始在那方面取得进展。是的，我不知道。生一个孩子并看着他们，比如他们吸收和学习了什么，这真是太迷人了
and the process of how they grow. But even, like, my daughter will see us do something in the kitchen or whatever, like, you know, do something with the pots and pans. And she has, like, a little play set of pots and pans. But they don't look like our pots and pans, other than roughly resembling a similar shape um she has no ability like we've never really sat there and told her like this is a pot this is also a pot you know like we never went through labeling and said like these things are so but she'll watch us do something is you will see her observe her at her play kitchen washing her hands under a fake faucet
以及他们生长的过程。但甚至，比如我女儿会看到我们在厨房里做一些事情什么的，比如，用锅碗瓢盆做一些事情。她有一套玩具锅碗瓢盆。但它们看起来不像我们的锅碗瓢盆，除了大致相似的形状嗯，她没有能力——我们从来没有真正坐在那里告诉她，这是一个锅，这也是一个锅，你知道的，就像我们从未经历过贴标签并说这些东西是这样的，但她会看着我们做一些事情，你会看到她在她的玩具厨房里观察她在假水龙头下洗手
that looks nothing like our faucet and doesn't emit water right and so she recognizes that this thing that i have here is the same as that thing over there and she's able to kind of she doesn't know necessarily why she's doing it but she wants to do the things that we do and she's able to figure that out all on her own and it's like wow to make a computer do that that'd be like really hard like i'm gonna do that no like amazing yeah absolutely amazing and i mean she's only able to do that because think of how much information she's digested. I mean, it's way more than that crawl, open crawl database, you know, 100 times over, right?
这看起来一点也不像我们的水龙头，也不会流水，对吧？所以她认识到我这里的这个东西和那边那个东西是一样的，她能够——她不一定知道自己为什么要这么做，但她想做我们做的事情，并且她能够完全靠自己弄清楚这一点，这就像——哇，让计算机做到这一点，那将是——真的很难——我要做到这一点——不，就像——太惊人了，绝对太惊人了，我的意思是她之所以能做到这一点，是因为想想她消化了多少信息。我的意思是，这比那个抓取（Crawl）、开放抓取数据库要多得多，你知道，多了一百倍，对吧？
Maybe a thousand times over. So yeah, it's amazing. And that's one problem that, you know, has to be cracked still. So we'll just sort of wrap up what is AI. There's some general goals for AI, which I feel are pretty universal. So one is deducing.
也许大了一千倍。所以，是的，这太神奇了。这就是仍然需要破解的一个问题。因此，我们将总结一下什么是人工智能。人工智能有一些总体目标，我觉得这些目标是非常普遍的。一个是推导。
So in other words, have you heard of the canonical monkey-banana problem? No. So the idea is there's a banana hanging from the ceiling and there's a chair against the wall and uh and if you just leave a monkey in a room long enough the monkey will start to swing at the banana but he can't reach because it's too far out of his reach um and then he'll start to understand like to take the chair move it in the middle of the room climb on the chair and then get the banana so the idea is the monkey have to sort of envision the future where he's standing on the chair and then get the banana so the idea is the monkey have to sort of envision
换句话说，你听说过经典的猴子香蕉问题吗？没有。所以这个想法是一根香蕉挂在天花板上，墙边有一把椅子，呃，如果你把一只猴子留在房间里足够长的时间，猴子就会开始向香蕉挥舞，但他够不到，因为离他太远了，呃，然后他就会开始明白——把椅子搬到房间中间，爬上椅子，然后拿到香蕉——所以这个想法是猴子必须在脑海中想象出他站在椅子上的未来，然后拿到香蕉，所以这个想法是猴子必须在脑海中想象出
the future where he's standing on the chair do some planning etc so that's deducing there's also reasoning so just um reasoning involves a lot of sort of looking at the past and using that to determine the future right so i know i touched a stove it it hurt me i got burned okay i'm not going to touch those right and there's alsosolving which is gets an expert systems and things like that and we'll definitely talk about all those in more detail in the next episode so what are some of the challenge like we talked about maybe some of what we thought AI would be and how we didn't get there so I mean there's obviously some things that got in the way yeah yeah definitely so yeah one thing that got in the way is
他站在椅子上的未来，做一些计划等等，这就是推导；还有推理——所以仅仅是，呃，推理涉及到大量回顾过去并利用它来决定未来的事情，对吧？所以我知道我摸了炉子，它伤害了我，我被烫伤了，好吧，我不会再去摸那些了。还有求解，这涉及到专家系统之类的事情，我们肯定会在下一集中更详细地讨论所有这些。那么有哪些挑战呢——就像我们讨论的，也许是我们对人工智能的一些期望以及我们是如何没有达到那一步的——所以我的意思是，显然有一些事情挡了路。
this concept of strong AI so people people wanted, you know, people had sort of reverse engineered the brain at a very low level. They hadn't done anything with DNA, which is, you know, as we talked about, you know, a huge folly, right? But they said, oh, if I have two neurons, one, you know, signals the other one like this. And so our brain has, I think it's like a trillion neurons. So if I just do this a trillion times, I'll have a human brain. And that doesn't work. Now I'm sure everyone listening to the show knows why. But their idea of recreating a human really kind of set AI back.
是的，绝对的。所以，是的，挡路的一件事是强人工智能这个概念——人们想要，你知道的，人们以非常低的水平对大脑进行了逆向工程。他们没有对 DNA 做任何事情，你知道的，正如我们所讨论的，（这是一个）巨大的愚蠢行为，对吧？但他们说，哦，如果我有两个神经元，一个，你知道的，向另一个发出信号，就像这样。所以我们的大脑，我想大约有一万亿个神经元。所以如果我把这个重复一万亿次，我就会拥有一个人类大脑。这行不通。现在我确信听节目的每个人都知道原因。但他们重建人类的想法确实让人工智能倒退了。
Another problem is whenever you're doing planning or reasoning, you have what's called the combinatorial explosion so let's just take checkers for example so on average in checkers there's I think like 2.5 moves you can make that are reasonable on average so if you're looking at a certain board there's let's say two moves you can make so you're now you're looking at two boards but in each of those boards there's another two moves you can do it so now you know it just explodes right there's also the knowledge representation so this is an incredibly difficult right how is knowledge actually stored one
另一个问题是，每当你进行规划或推理时，你就会遇到所谓的“组合爆炸”。所以让我们以跳棋为例——在跳棋中，平均而言，我认为大约有 2.5 步你可以采取的合理的移动。如果你正在看某个棋盘，假设你可以走两步，所以你现在看到的是两个棋盘。但在其中每一个棋盘上，你还可以做另外两步，所以现在，你知道，它直接就爆炸了，对吧？还有知识表示——这真是极其困难，对吧？知识实际上是如何存储的？一个
common thing that you hear of is humans can only remember seven things at a time that's why most phone digits most phone numbers are seven digits, right? But we do this thing called chunking, where you might remember seven things, but each of those seven things is incredibly complex. And so you've sort of like collapsed a bunch of information into one quote-unquote thing that you have to remember, right? And that's what video games are all about. Like in mario it's kind of all about the context like if you're jumping over a pit you know that you have like no room for error but if you're jumping to hit you know a block to get a
你经常听到的一件常见的事情是，人类一次只能记住七件事。这就是为什么大多数电话号码都是七位数字的原因，对吧？但我们做了一件叫做“组块”（chunking）的事情，你可能会记住七件事，但这七件事中的每一件都极其复杂。所以你有点像把一堆信息压缩成一个你必须记住的所谓“东西”，对吧？这就是电子游戏所关心的。比如在《马里奥》中，这几乎全关乎上下文——如果你正跳过一个深坑，你知道你几乎没有犯错的余地；但如果你跳起来去撞击（你知道的）一个方块来获得一个
mushroom or something you're much more relaxed like you might try and do that and hit a goomba at the same time or something like that so So in video games, you kind of chunk different actions based on their context. So finally, the biggest challenge in AI is what's called the frame problem. And the frame problem is basically you don't know what affects a certain action. So, for example, let's say you're getting out of your car, and you want to know if now is a good time to get out of your car. So clearly, if the car is moving 50 miles an hour, that's probably not a good time to step out of your car, right? Unless you're being held hostage.
蘑菇什么的，你会放松得多——你可能会尝试这样做，同时撞到一个栗宝宝（Goomba）什么的。所以，在电子游戏中，你会根据它们的上下文把不同的动作组合成块。最后，人工智能中最大的挑战被称为“框架问题”（The frame problem）。框架问题基本上就是你不知道什么会影响某个特定的动作。所以，举个例子，假设你正要下车，你想知道现在是不是下车的好时机。很明显，如果汽车正以每小时 50 英里的速度行驶，那可能不是迈出汽车的好时机，对吧？除非你被当作人质。
Yeah, yeah. Then you could do like a barrel roll or something. But probably not at 50. No, yeah, maybe not. Maybe slow slow to 30 and then barrel roll okay but the the point is like you know the the current temperature in the current temperature in france for everyone who's not in france right now does not matter whether you know if the car is going 50 miles an hour if it's not matters a lot more than the temperature in france for as to whether you should get out of your car or not. But how do you know what should matter and what shouldn't when you're making decisions? That's the crux of the frame problem.
对，对。然后你可以做一个桶滚（barrel roll）或者别的什么。但可能不是在 50 英里时速下。不，是的，也许不是。也许减速到 30（英里时速）然后做桶滚，好吧。但重点是——你知道的——法国当前的温度——对于不在法国的每个人来说——并不重要（你知道的）如果汽车以每小时 50 英里的速度行驶，它是否重要，远比法国的温度更重要，关乎你是否应该下车。但是当你做决定时，你怎么知道什么重要，什么不重要？这就是框架问题的核心所在。
So if you don't know what matters and what doesn't, then you have to consider every possible thing that could exist. And also, the next time you make that decision, you don't really know what made that decision a good or bad idea the first time, right? Because how do you know that the weather in France isn't the reason why last time you got out of your car and you were hit by a bike, right? So knowing sort of what the context is for a particular decision is the frame problem. And that's actually extremely difficult. I guess that's a good thing about AIs for games because it already frames the problem for you. Yeah, that's why games and AI are sort of intertwined. Okay. So we're kind of like giving a little tour, like background, speaking at a very high level.
因此，如果你不知道什么重要、什么不重要，你就必须考虑可能存在的每一件可能的事情。而且，下次你做出那个决定时，你其实并不知道是什么让那个决定在第一次成为一个好主意或坏主意，对吧？因为你怎么知道法国的天气不是你上次下车时被自行车撞了的原因，对吧？所以，了解某个特定决定的背景是什么，就是框架问题。这其实非常困难。我想这是游戏人工智能的一个好处，因为它已经为你构筑了问题的框架。是的，这就是游戏和人工智能交织在一起的原因。好吧。所以我们有点像是在进行一次小小的观光，提供背景知识，站在一个非常高的层面上。
Hopefully this is interesting to you. We're going to get to some specifics and some more hardcore stuff in the next episode. But kind of wrap up here, we want to talk a little bit about some of the cool things AI is used for. We talked a lot about games, but there are some other things that are kind of classic examples of what AI gives us or attempts to give us. Yeah, you want to go first? Okay, so first one is Maxima, the computer algebra expert system. So it's something that's able to solve algebra.
希望这对你很有趣。我们将在下一集中探讨一些具体细节和更硬核的东西。但在这里做个收尾，我们想多聊聊人工智能被用于的一些很酷的事情。我们讨论了很多关于游戏的内容，但还有一些其他东西可以说是人工智能给我们带来的或试图给我们带来的经典例子。是的，你想先说吗？好吧，那么第一个是 Maxima，即计算机代数专家系统。所以它是能够解决代数问题的系统。
Yeah, totally. Okay, that was your point. I thought you were going to go straight to Eliza. Oh, well, I'll talk about Eliza, and then you can talk about Maxima. So mine, of course, sticking with useless things is eliza chatbot so this was you know kind of like the early you may have seen it before i remember seeing it at like a science center when i was a little kid yeah they actually have it um i was at the uh moma that san francisco moma has an eliza
是的，完全正确。好吧，那是你的观点。我还以为你要直接谈 Eliza 呢。哦，好吧，我会谈谈 Eliza，然后你可以谈谈 Maxima。所以我的，当然，坚持无用之物——是 Eliza 聊天机器人。所以这你知道的，有点像早期的版本，你以前可能见过它。我记得我小时候在科学中心见过它。是的，他们实际上有它，呃，我在——我在现代艺术博物馆（MOMA），旧金山现代艺术博物馆有一个 Eliza。
oh okay yeah so it's like a computer it says like i forget what they're greeting like hello what's your name or something you type you know my name is patrick hi patrick how are you doing today i'm doing good i'm glad to hear you're doing good you know or something and then it kind of so it looks for like certain keywords and tries to create a sentence or alter what you said in a certain way to make it get back often get stuck and just kind of says like i don't know what that is or something you know but um know, it kind of gives you this illusion almost for just a second that, whoa, wait, what's happening? Am I really talking to somebody else? Yeah, it takes some of what you say and sort of puts it in its next statement.
哦，好吧，是的，就像一台计算机，它说，像——我忘了它们的问候语是什么——你好，你叫什么名字什么的。你键入，你知道，我叫帕特里克。你好，帕特里克，你今天过得怎么样？我过得很好。很高兴听到你过得不错，你知道，诸如此类。然后它有点——所以它会寻找某些关键词，并试图创建一个句子或以某种方式改变你所说的话，使其能够恢复——通常会卡住，然后有点像说，我不知道那是什么或者诸如此类的东西，你知道，但是——你知道，它几乎在短短的一秒钟内给你一种错觉，哇，等等，发生了什么？我真的是在和别人说话吗？是的，它采用你所说的一部分，并将其放入它的下一个陈述中。
Like you might say, I don't like diapers. And it will say, oh, tell me more about diapers. And so you feel like, oh, wow, he's really answering me. Yeah. Did I tell you I actually, and my wife was really embarrassed, but I actually, I know of a way to trick these chatbots because, so if you don't know, I got a PhD in AI and machine learning. So done this stuff for a long time. And I kind of, so I, so here's a pro tip. If you've ever seen Eliza bot at a museum or something, you can say something to the
就像你可能会说，我不喜欢尿布。它会说，哦，跟我多讲讲尿布的事。所以你会觉得，哦，天哪，它真的在回答我。是的。我有没有告诉你，实际上，我的妻子真的很尴尬，但我实际上，我知道一种欺骗这些聊天机器人的方法，因为——如果你不知道的话，我获得了人工智能和机器学习的博士学位。所以做过这些事情很长时间了。我有点——所以，这里有一个专业提示。如果你曾经在博物馆或其他地方见过 Eliza 机器人，你可以说一些类似于
effect of like what I said I said oh I really don't like flies and Eliza said oh it tell me more about flies I said well I also don't like bananas and she said something I remember what she does like done but then this is the catch you say no fruit flies like a banana and so you think about it there's two ways to take that like no fruit flies like a banana or no fruit flies like a banana and it flipped out and it said this is X so I've done this before and it just said like I don't understand or does not computers on the right but this time it literally said I I joke you not. Did you just wet yourself?
我所说的话——我说，哦，我真的不喜欢苍蝇，Eliza 说，哦，跟我多讲讲苍蝇的事。我说，嗯，我也不喜欢香蕉。她说了一些——我不记得她说了什么——像“完成”一样。但随后这是关键：你说：“不，果蝇喜欢香蕉（No, fruit flies like a banana / Fruit flies like a banana）。”所以你仔细想想，有两种理解方式：不，果蝇喜欢香蕉（No, fruit flies like a banana），或者水果飞得像一根香蕉（Fruit flies like a banana / 果蝇喜欢香蕉）。它崩溃了，它说，这是 X。所以我以前做过这个，它只是说，像，我不明白，或者计算机不正确，但这一次它字面意思是——我没开玩笑。你刚才尿裤子了吗？
Is what it said. Literally. And, like, everybody around is, like, just busting out. It said something like, I don't understand. Did you wet yourself? Well, I was so embarrassed. It was pretty epic. I kind of want to go try this now.
这就是它所说的。字面意思。而且，像，周围每个人，就像，直接爆笑。它说了一些类似的话，我不明白。你尿裤子了吗？嗯，我太尴尬了。这真是太史诗级了。我有点想去试试这个了。
Yeah. You should definitely go to the moment. Give us a shout. Okay. All right. So, yeah. So, I'll cover Maximo. Yeah, since I definitely go to the moment and give us a shot. Okay, all right. So, yeah, so we'll cover Maxima. Yeah, since I butchered it by just reading what you wrote on the page. So Maxima is an algebra expert system.
是的。你绝对应该去现代艺术博物馆（MOMA）。给我们大声喊出来。好吧。好的。所以，是的。所以，我会讲 Maxima。是的，既然我只是通过阅读你写在纸上的东西把它给搞砸了。所以 Maxima 是一个代数专家系统。
We'll cover expert systems more later, but you can think of it as sort of like searching, but instead of searching through moves and checkers, it's searching through things that you can do in algebra, like dividing or canceling this number out or you know removing an X from both sides etc. And so it does really complex integrals and differential equations and things like that. Like if any of our listeners are in high school or university and they're taking I think it's what Calc 2 or something like that where you study integrals and you
我们稍后会更多地讨论专家系统，但你可以把它想象成某种搜索，只不过它不是在跳棋的走法中搜索，而是在你可以在代数中做的事情中搜索，比如除法或抵消这个数字，或者你知道的，从两边移除一个 X 等等。所以它可以做非常复杂的积分、微分方程之类的事情。就像如果我们的任何听众在上高中或大学，他们正在修——我想是微积分 2 或者是学习积分的类似课程，并且你
have to memorize all these crazy rules like the trig rule, like the derivative of sine is cosine and derivative of sine squared is 1 minus cosine squared. I mean, all these crazy rules. So this system, Maxima, knows about all these crazy rules and then it will try different rules and get in and hone in on the solution. So you can say, give me the integral of this huge equation, and it will sort of crunch the numbers and figure it out for you.
必须记住所有这些疯狂的规则，比如三角规则，比如正弦的导数是余弦，正弦平方的导数是 1 减去余弦平方。我的意思是，所有这些疯狂的规则。所以这个系统，Maxima，知道所有这些疯狂的规则，然后它会尝试不同的规则并进入并锁定解决方案。所以你可以说，给我这个庞大方程的积分，它会帮你计算数字并弄清楚它。
Another useful project which used AI was the DARPA Grand Challenge. So this was, you know, create a self-driving car that'll drive across the desert and then through a mock city. And this was kind of, you know, first year was like a horrible disaster. They did it again was kind of you know first year was like a horrible disaster they did it again and like you know it was much much better and you know even just like the you know five years or whatever i guess between the how many years was between the first
另一个使用人工智能的有用项目是 DARPA 挑战赛（DARPA Grand Challenge）。所以这是，你知道的，制造一辆自动驾驶汽车，它将穿过沙漠，然后穿过一个模拟城市。这有点像，你知道的，第一年就像是一场可怕的灾难。他们再次这样做——这有点像，你知道的，第一年就像是一场可怕的灾难。他们再次这样做，并且像，你知道的，它要好得多，并且你知道的，甚至就像——你知道的，五年左右，或者我猜在——第一场比赛和他们做的最后一场比赛之间有多少年，你知道的——就像有一个巨大的进步，并且你知道的——它们能做得多好，并且你知道的——不仅是按照你希望的方式操纵车辆的复杂性，而且还要识别你想去哪里，并且，你知道的，要避开什么，并且，你知道的，所有这些事情。而且这只是，你知道的，需要大量的规划、智能，达到，就像你所说的，强人工智能能够解决所有问题，你知道的，并试图将它们组合在某样东西中。并不是说自动驾驶汽车解决了所有问题，而是这些问题，但为了能够从 A 点到 B 点，它必须解决人工智能的许多不同方面。
one and the final one that they did you know like there's just like a huge progression and like you know how good they could do and you know just the complexity of not only just steering the vehicle the way you want it to go, but recognizing where you want to go and, you know, what to avoid and, you know, all these things. And it's just, you know, it takes a lot of planning, intelligence, getting to, like you talked about, the strong guy being able to kind of like solve all the problems, you know, and trying to put them together in something. Not that a self-driving car solves all of the problems, but the problems, but it has to solve many different kind of aspects of AI in order to be able to get from point A to point B.
因为这不仅仅像从 A 点移动到 B 点。这就像，嗯，我该怎么移动？到达那里的最好方法是什么？我如何避免伤害自己或伤害他人或所有这些事情？是的，他们举办了沙漠挑战赛（Grand Challenge）。然后最近他们举办了——城市挑战赛（Urban Grand Challenge），我后来发现它并不是真正的
Because it's not just like move from point A to point B. It's like, well, how do I move? What's the best way to get there? How do I avoid damaging myself or damaging others or all these things? Yeah, they did the Grand Challenge, which was out in the desert. And then recently they did the grand challenge which was out in the desert and then recently they did an urban grand challenge which i found out later wasn't really
城市——就像一个假的城市环境，所以没有人真正处于危险之中。好吧，有开其他车的司机。是的，但他们是——是的，他们是——是的，是的，是的，仍然很酷。所以，嗯，我们再做一个，好吧。所以这很酷。它是 RoboCup 机器人世界杯足球赛。基本上我们的目标是——我不记得这是什么时候开始的。在我上大学的某个时候。但基本上当它开始时，目标是在 50 年内在世界杯上让一个完全自主的人形机器人足球队参赛。所以在 2047 年之前，让全尺寸的人形机器人与（你知道的）比如德国队争夺世界杯决赛。所以这是一个相当雄心勃勃的目标。他们得到了来自 ACM 和其他组织的大量支持
urban like it was a fake urban setting so no one was actually at risk well there were people driving the other cars yeah but they were yeah they were like yeah yeah yeah still pretty cool so um yeah we'll do one more okay so this is pretty cool. It's RoboCup Soccer. And basically the goal is, I don't remember when this started. Sometime while I was in university. But basically when it started, the goal was to have a fully autonomous humanoid robot soccer team compete in the World Cup in 50 years. So by 2047, to have like full-sized human robots competing against, you know, like Germany for the World Cup finals. So pretty ambitious goal. They have an incredible amount of backing from like ACM and other organizations
大量有趣的人工智能。我的另一个学生或与我在大学实验室一起的另一个学生正在研究这个问题，他们在过去几年中取得的进展数量真是太惊人了。他们实际上已经——他们将其分为几个领域。他们拥有全尺寸的人形机器人问题。在这一点上，他们有点像在罚点球。他们在那方面并没有取得太大的进展。但如果你仔细想想，那成本非常高。所以这有点像最后一步。
a lot of interesting AI another student of mine or another student that was with me in the lab at university was working on this problem and it's just pretty amazing the amount of progress they've done they actually have they sort of split it up into several domains they have the full-sized humanoid problem. And at that point, they're kind of like doing penalty kicks. And they haven't really made too much progress there. But if you think about it, that's very expensive. So that's kind of like the last step.
但现在他们有某种规模较小的比赛，由真正的机器人四处奔跑并踢足球等。这太棒了。维基百科链接应该会指向一些足球比赛的相当精彩的视频。在节目笔记中，是的。是的，如果没有，我们会添加一些视频。但这绝对棒极了，我强烈建议去看看。这很有趣，不过。
But now they have sort of a smaller scale competitions with real robots that run around and kick soccer balls and stuff. It's pretty awesome. The Wikipedia link should point to some pretty epic videos of soccer matches. In the show notes, yep. Yeah, if not, we'll add some videos. But it's totally awesome, and I highly recommend checking that out. So that's interesting, though.
我们刚讨论了游戏中的人工智能，但这里实际上是在解决一个更困难的问题，而不是仅仅一个——而且我认为他们甚至确实有一个模拟，模拟联赛什么的。但现在你试图去踢球，你知道的，这是——它是同时进行的，而不是轮流进行的。所以如果你花更长的时间来弄清楚你要做什么，
We just talked about AI in-game, but here's actually getting a harder problem as opposed to just a— and I think they even do have a simulation, simulation league or whatever. But now you're trying to play, you know, it's, it's simultaneous as opposed to taking turns. So if you take longer to figure out what you're going to do,
你知道，这很糟糕。其他人也四处乱跑。是的。你知道，然后还有——不得不，再次回到大挑战赛的事情上，
you know, like that's bad. Other people run around too. Yeah. You know, and then also like having to, again, getting back to like what the grand challenge thing,
在现实世界中处理它，不仅要弄清楚你想要做什么，还要弄清楚你将如何去做——是的，就像你实际上是如何做到这一点的。是的，这件有趣的事情，你认为他们会成功吗——所以 2047 年，2013 年，在 30 年内，我认为他们——我认为他们会有人形机器人踢足球，我不知道他们是否会参加世界杯。我不太确定的一件事是，
like dealing with it in the real world, not only get to figure out what, what you want to do, but how you're going to do it yeah like how do you actually do this yeah this interesting thing do you think they'll make it um so 2047 2013 in 30 years i think that they i think that they'll have humanoids playing soccer i don't know if they'll compete in the world cup one thing i wasn't sure about is, if a robot slide tackles you, does it just matter to you, right? I mean, how does that work?
如果一个机器人飞铲你，这对你来说重要吗，对吧？我的意思是，那是怎么运作的？
But obviously, I mean, I don't think the rules probably permit them to play. They probably don't meet the anti-doping rules. No, something, right? Like, they probably don't meet the rules. So you'd have to create a scenario in order to allow them to play, right? Like, you're not allowed to make contact i don't know
但显然，我的意思是，我不认为规则可能允许他们踢球。他们可能不符合反兴奋剂规则。不，有什么东西，对吧？就像，他们可能不符合规则。所以你必须创建一个场景才能允许他们玩，对吧？比如，你不被允许进行身体接触——我不知道。
that's not really fair that's the thing is like i don't really know how they would do deal with that part of it you know so i feel like that's where the actual limitation is going to be like the ai will be sufficiently capable but you know just the mechanics of taking the stripping the ball from another player and not destroying them is gonna be the hard part Yeah, you have to you have to have the robots implement as mobs three laws. Yeah Then the players can't do anything Because the humans will just tackle the robots Okay, well I think that wraps it up for for this episode so next episode we're gonna be talking about
这其实不太公平。这就是问题所在——就像我真的不知道他们将如何处理其中的那一部分，你知道的，所以我觉得这才是实际的限制所在——就像人工智能将有足够的胜任能力，但你知道的，从另一个球员脚下抢断球而不摧毁他们的机制将是困难的部分。是的，你必须——你必须让机器人实现阿西莫夫三定律。是的，然后球员们什么也做不了，因为人类只会去铲机器人。好吧，我想这为这一集画上了句号。所以下一集我们将讨论
You know in depth kind of how do you actually get these AI problems done? Like what are the tools and techniques you're going to use? Yeah. By the end of the next episode, you'll be able to actually solve AI problems on your own. Or at least know what to go look up to work. Yeah. Using other people's source code. Yes. You'll know the google search that will give you the answer yeah um all right well i think that's it for us for now cool have a good one guys
你知道，深入探讨一下你实际上是如何完成这些人工智能问题的？比如你将使用什么工具和技术？是的。到下一集结束时，你将能够自己解决人工智能问题。或者至少知道去查阅什么来工作。是的。使用别人的源代码。是的。你会知道谷歌搜索会给你答案。好的，好吧，我想我们现在就到这里了。酷，祝大家过得愉快。
the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
片头曲是 Biner Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 以知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证发行。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，可以重新混合、改编该作品，但你必须对我和帕特里克进行署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。